ORGANIZATION WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE CUP IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
WAS LIMIT NON ESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING AN ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHAT
CONDUCTING THE HEARINGS IN A
WAY THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC IN OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE BEEN DEAD MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WEST. TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. TO PARTICIPATE
IN TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. YOU WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT HERE IN A MOMENT.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHTY FIVE.
SEVENTY NINE SEVEN FIFTY. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AMMAN- MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY
YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE
AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
NHIáU THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL I
WILL TRY TO MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN INDIAN EIGHT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTED
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE- REMOTE
AT MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTION MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. HE IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME. MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE USE. THAT NEW
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT
TO ALL INTERESTED PARTIES SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. FOR WE HEAR THE
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL. LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM I WANT TO
REMIND MEMBERS TO WAIT UNTIL
THE MICROPHONE IS TURNED ON AND
PLEASE SPEAK INTO THE
MICROPHONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. DONNA. HERE BAD
HERE WILK PRESIDENT DOT WILL
PRESENT ALLEN. ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA PRESIDENT BORDERS.
BORDERS PRESENT BRADFORD.
REFERENCE HERE CHIANG PRESENT
THANK PRESIDENT GALGIANI.
GALGIANI PRESIDENT GLAZER. HILL
HELLO HERE WHAT'S SO. NIELSEN
PORTANTINO AIR TWENTY NO HERE
RUBIO. WIENER WHERE PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM GERMAN. THE
SECRETARY KNOWS OF A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED OKAY NOW IT'S
TIME TO HEAR FROM OUR AUTHOR.
GERMAN DODD AND YOU MAY NOT
PERCENT SCA SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND GIVING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
SCA SIX. I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO EXPLAIN THE REASONS
WHY I DECIDED TO BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD. I'M NOT SOMEONE
WHO GAMBLES WARS LOOKING TO DO
SPORTS WAGERING MYSELF. THIS
ISN'T FOR A FUN EASY ISSUE
EITHER. THE REASONS ARE SIMPLE.
I BELIEVE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS A DUTY TO THE PEOPLE OF OUR
STATE. WE HAVE A DUTY TO BRING
ILLEGAL SPORTS WAGERING OUT OF
THE SHADOWS IN SUPPORTER
COMMUNITIES WITH THE REVENUE
THAT WILL BE GENERATED. NEARLY
HALF THE LEGALIZE SPORTS
WAGERING. NEARLY HALF OF THE
NATION EXCUSE ME HAS LEGALIZED
SPORTS WAGERING AND WE SHOULD
DO IT HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN A
WAY THAT MAXIMIZES BENEFITS TO
THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE. WHEN I
BECAME CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
THREE YEARS AGO. I SUDDENLY
FOUND MYSELF IN THE MIDDLE OF A
VERY FRACTURED RELATIONSHIP
THAT HAS EXISTED BETWEEN CARD
ROOMS OF THE TRIBES FOR WAY
LONG BEFORE I BECAME CHAIR. AS
CHAIR OF GEO IN ALONG SIDE
CHAIRMAN GRAY WE BELIEVED IT
WAS TIME TO TRY TO WORK
TOGETHER ON A SOLUTION. I
BELIEVE THAT THE LEGISLATION OF
SPORTS WAGERING PROVIDES THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP EVERYONE IN
THE GAMING INDUSTRY IT'S A
PROVIDE AS MUCH REVENUE TO OUR
STATE. DURING THIS TOUGH
ECONOMIC TIMES. I KNOW THERE
ARE PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES WHO'LL
NEVER AGREE TO A SOLUTION. BUT
I HOPE THAT IF YOU TAKE A
MOMENT TO REALLY LOOK AT WHAT
THIS BILL IS. UNDERSTANDING
THAT IT IS STILL A WORK IN
PROGRESS YOU WILLCOME TO THE
SAME CONCLUSION THAT I HAVE.
THAT WE CANNOT AFFORD. INACTION
UNDER THIS BILL THE TRIED TO
GAIN THE ABILITY TO OFFER CRAPS
ROULETTE AS WELL AS THE ABILITY
TO CONDUCT SPORTS WAGERING BOTH
AT THEIR TRIBAL CASINOS AIR AND
ONLINE. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
HORSE RACING IS CURRENTLY THE
ONLY INDUSTRY AUTHORIZED TO
CONDUCT MOBILE WAGERING. THIS
BILL WILL SIMILAR SIMILARLY
AUTHORIZE HORSE RACING COULD
CONDUCTS WARTS WAGERING ONLINE
AS WELL AS OF THEIR BREAK IN
MORTAR LOCATIONS. THE CARD
ROOMS WOULD NOT LET ME REPEAT
THAT CARD ROOMS WOULD NOT BE
AUTHORIZED TO CONDUCT SPORTS
WAGERING. BUT MY INTENTION IS
TO PROVIDE CARD ROOMS WITH
CLARITY ON THE GAMES THEY PLAY.
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
LEGALIZATION OF SPORTS WAGERING
NOT ONLY PROVIDES A NEW REVENUE
SORTS SOURCE WHICH IS
ESTIMATED. AS HIGH AS FIVE
HUNDRED TO SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN A
MATURE MARKET. BUT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THIS
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY OUT OF THE
SHADOWS. MEMBERS WE MUST BE
HONEST WITH OURSELVES SPORTS
BETTING. IS AND WILL CONTINUE
TO OCCUR IN CALIFORNIA
REGARDLESS OF ITS LEGALITY. A
VOTE FOR THE LEGALIZATION OF
SPORTS WAGERING. IT'S SUPPOSED
TO REGULATE THE INDUSTRY TO
PROTECT OUR CONSTITUENTS IT TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. GETS ITS FAIR SHARE.
I APPRECIATE THE RECENT OUT
REACH FROM TRIBAL LEADERS
ESPECIALLY RINCON BAND OF
LOOSELY NEO- INDIANS CHAIRMAN
BO WAS ATTY. FOR A WILLINGNESS
AND COMMITMENT TO ENGAGE IN
SUBSTANTIVE GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS TO ADDRESS SOME
OUTSTANDING ISSUES IN THIS BILL.
IT'S A VERY HONORABLE OVERTURE
AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
COME TOGETHER WORK OUT DETAILS
ESPECIALLY AROUND THE CAR ROOM
ISSUE. BASED ON OUR DEADLINES
WE NEED TO MOVE FOR WITH OUR
COMMITTEE VOTE TODAY. BUT I
HAVE COMMITTED TO COME TO THE
TABLE FOR THOSE SUBSTANTIVE
GOOD FAITH NEGOTIATIONS AND I
WILL NOT BRING THIS BILL UP ON
THE FLOOR BEFORE WE HAD A
CHANCE FOR THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
EIGHTY BILL WE BRING TO THE
FLOOR WILL HAVE AMENDMENTS TO
HELP ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF
THE TRIBES. THERE'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT WORK TODAY. AND I
KNOW THERE IS A LOT OF WORK YET
TO BE DONE ON THIS ISSUE. I
BELIEVE WE CAN ADVANCE A
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTION. IT'S A
WIN WIN BUT IT ALL STARTS WITH
THE COMMITTEE ADVANCING SCA SIX
HERE TODAY. I WOULD NOW LIKE TO
TURN- MISTER CHAIRMAN IT OVER
TO SHERMAN GRAY WHO WILL
PROVIDE A FEW COMMENTS. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SAID A
FEW WORDS ON SCA SIX. HI THIS
IS A JOINT EFFORT. ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND SENATOR DODD THE TO
RESPECTIVE POLICY COMMITTEE
CHAIRS HERE TO STAY LEGISLATURE
THIS IS AN ISSUE WE WORKED ON.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS SO. THERE'S
GONNA BE LAW LOBBYING. AROUND
THIS BILL THERE SHOULD BE A LOT
OF- MISGUIDED COMMENTS AND
ACCUSATIONS ABOUT NOBODY WAS
TOLD THIS OR SOMEBODY WASN'T
TOLD THAT OR WHATEVER WE CAN
TALK ABOUT OTHER THAN
SUBSTANCE. THE SUBSTANCE IS
SIMPLE HERE WE'VE GOT A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT THAT
WE'RE ALL GOING TO STRUGGLE
WITH. THIS YEAR. SPORTS WORK
WAGERING OCCURS IN EACH AND
EVERY SENATORS DISTRICT ON THE
FOR THERE'S NOT A ONE OF YOU
WHO DOESN'T HAVE CONSTITUENTS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY BETTING ON
SPORTS. ON ILLEGAL UNREGULATED
ONLINE APPS THAT'S BEEN GOING
ON FOR YEARS AND IT WILL
CONTINUE TO GO ON. THE CHOICE
TODAY IS DO WE WANT TO REGULATE
THAT MARKET HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
TAX THAT MARKET HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND REYES AS MUCH AS
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO WELL
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX
REVENUE THAT CAN HELP US
NAVIGATE THESE UNCERTAIN AND
DIFFICULT TIMES. RIGHT A BETTER
PRODUCT FOR THE- SPORTS FAN AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ENJOY SPORTS
WAGERING ALSO PROVIDE ANOTHER
PRODUCT FOR THE BUSINESSES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. THE INCLUDE. OUR
HORSE RACING FACILITIES. AND
OUR TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND
THEIR CASINOS. THEY CURRENTLY
ARE UNABLE TO OFFER A VEGAS
STYLE PROJECT THIS AMENDMENT
WILL ALLOW THEM TO COMPETE HEAD
TO HEAD. WITH OUR NEIGHBOR
NEVADA AND OFFER A FULL LINE OF
GAMES INCLUDING SPORTS WAGERING
INCLUDING A CRAPS AND ROULETTE
AND SLOT MACHINES THEY WILL BE
THE EXCLUSIVE. ENTITY THAT CAN
OFFER THAT. AT THE SAME TIME WE
CAN TAKE THE REVENUES FROM
ONLINE SPORTS WAGERING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND DO A LOT OF GOOD
FOR CALIFORNIANS I SAT ON THE
FLOOR RECENTLY IT. IS AWFULLY
HARD FOR ANY OF US TO GO HOME
AND EXPLAIN TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT WE RESPONDED TO THE
GREATEST PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
THE LAST HUNDRED YEARS. BY
CUTTING HEALTHCARE. LET'S TAKE
EVERY STEP WE CAN MEMBERS TO
ENSURE THAT WE- DON'T HAVE TO
MAKE THOSE CUTS THESE ARE
DIFFICULT TIMES OF DIFFICULT
CHOICES ARE GOING TO BE HAVE TO
BE MADE THAT'S A CERTAIN. BUT
LET'S NOT LET LET'S TAKE STEPS
TO REDUCE THAT. LET'S MOVE THIS
FORWARD LET'S BRING ALL THE
PARTIES TO THE TABLE. LET'S PUT
ASIDE SOME OF THE SILLY
LOBBYING AND GET TO THE
SUBSTANCE. OF WHAT CAN BENEFIT
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS WHAT CAN
BENEFIT OUR HORSE RACING
INDUSTRY ONE OF THE BEST IN THE
COUNTRY- AND LET THE TWO
CHAIRMEN OF THE TWO POLICY
COMMITTEES DO THE IMPORTANT
WORK TO BRING YOU MEMBERS A
BILL ON THE FLOOR. THAT WILL
HELP ALL CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN GRAY. NOW WE WILL MOVE
ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LINK THAT
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED A TOTAL OF
TEN MINUTES ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MISS LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO NAME. AFFILIATION
AND THE POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. CHAIRMAN DOT IT LEAVE
THE YOU HAVE SHOWN LAYING IN
ERNIE HERNANDEZ WHO ARE HERE IN
THE GALLERY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AS WELL AS CHRIS GROVE
ON THE PHONE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOE L<c.cyan>G REPRESENTING</c>
THE COALITION OF SUPPORTERS OF
ESSAYS SIX- I THANK YOU AND
HAVE THE UTMOST RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHORS FOR THE COMMITTEE. AND
DEEPEST RESPECT FOR THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS TO EXPRESS CONCERNS
WITH THIS LEGISLATION. I
BELIEVE CENTER DOT IN A SEVEN
GRAY HAVE PROBABLY ARTICULATED
HOW IMPORTANT THIS MEASURE IS
AND HOW IT MEETS THE TEST OF
BOTH SOUND PUBLIC POLICY AND
FAIR PUBLIC POLICY TO ALL THE
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS. THE
MEASURE MEETS THE STANDARD OF
SOUND PUBLIC POLICY FOR AT
LEAST THREE REASONS. ONE AT A
TIME WHEN THE STATE IS IN NEED
OF ADDITIONAL REVENUE IT WILL
PROVIDE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO THE STATE.
TO HELP AVOID DEVASTATING CUTS
TO IMPORTANT SERVICES. TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN YEAR ONE. AND FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUTURE YEARS. ALLOWING
CALIFORNIA TO COMPETE AGAINST
TWENTY THREE OTHER STATES WHO
HAVE AUTHORIZED SPORTS WAGERING
ALREADY. NUMBER TWO IT WILL
HELP TO ELIMINATE THE CURRENT
ILLEGAL SPORTS WAGERING MARKET.
ESTIMATED TO BE IN THE MANY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND GIVE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS A SAFE
LEGAL AND WELL REGULATED MANNER
IN WHICH TO PARTICIPATE. IT
WILL HELP TO PRESERVE HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LOCAL
REVENUE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHO ARE ALSO FACING THE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF CODE
NINETEEN TO THEIR ECONOMIES.
THE MEASURE BEFORE YOU ALSO
MEETS THE STANDARD OF A FAIR
AND EQUITABLE POLICY FOR THE
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED.
ONE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS CHOOSING
IN SOME CASES TO POSE AS
PLEASURE WOULD BENEFIT BY A THE
ABILITY TO CONDUCT SPORTS
WAGERING AT THEIR TRIBAL
CASINOS. IN THE SAME MANNER IN
WHICH. THE TITLE INITIATIVE
ALLOWED. BE THEY RECEIVE THE
ADDITIONAL BENEFIT OF BEING
ABLE TO CONDUCT ONLINE SPORTS
WAGERING BUT ONLY IF THEY
CHOOSE TO DO SO. THIS MEASURE
DOES NOT MANDATE THE CONDUCT OF
ONLINE WAGERING AT ALL. NUMBER
THREE THE MEASURE FURTHER
ALLOWS TRIBAL CASINOS TO OFFER
THE GAMES OF ROULETTE AND CRAPS
ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF
REVENUE FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ANOTHER WAY IT CREATES AN
EQUITABLE POLICY. IS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LICENSE CARD CLUBS.
IN THIS CASE IT WILL SIMPLY
ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE OFFERING
THE SAME GAMES THEY ARE
CURRENTLY OFFERING. THAT
AUTHORIZED TO PLAY IN THE SAME
MANNER IN WHICH THEY ARE
CURRENTLY PLAYED. WHAT CARD
CLUBS WOULD STRONGLY DESIRE TO
ALSO OFFER SPORTS WAGERING.
THIS MEASURE DOES NOT ALLOW
THAT AND CARD ROOMS ARE STILL
SUPPORTIVE OF THE MEASURE. FOR
THE VARIOUS PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
LEAGUES WHO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE IT OFFERS AN
EFFECTIVE WAY OF ELIMINATING
ILLEGAL WAGERING ON THEIR
SPORTING EVENTS. AND PROTECTING
THE INTEGRITY OF THEIR SPORTS.
AS ALSO MENTION BY THE AUTHORS
CALIFORNIA'S HORSE RACING
TRACKS BENEFIT AS THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO OFFER SPORTS WAGERING
IN THE SAME MANNER AS THE
INITIATIVE. ORIGINALLY AUTHORED
BY SOME TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. IN
ADDITION TO THE ALREADY
AUTHORIZED ONLINE WAGERING ON
HORSE RACING WHICH EXISTS TODAY.
SO WHAT'S MISSING FROM THIS
MEASURE. THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
THE TRIBAL EDITION. THAT IS A
PROVISION CREATING A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION. WHICH IS A
TOOL TO DISRUPT IF NOT TOTALLY
DESTROYED CALIFORNIA'S LICENSE
CARD ROOMS AS WE KNOW THAT. SO
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN THE REAL
WORLD THAT THIS MEASURE PASSES
AND IS APPROVED BY THE VOTERS.
ONE TRIBAL CASINOS WILL BENEFIT
BY OFFERING SPORTS WAGERING
CRAPS AND ROULETTE. TWO CAR
CLUBS WILL CONTINUE TO EXIST AS
WE KNOW THEM TODAY. THREE THE
STATE WILL REALIZE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN GREATLY
NEEDED REVENUE. AND FOR
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT REVENUE
WILL BE PRESERVED. ALL OF THOSE
ARE POSITIVE RESULTS AND
DEPENDENT UPON EACH OTHER. YOU
MAY HEAR FROM OPPONENTS TODAY
THAT THIS MEASURE ACTUALLY
GIVES THE CAR CLUBS A
SUBSTANTIAL EXPANSION OF
GAMBLING BY ALLOWING THEM TO
EXIST AND PLAY THE GAMES THAT
THEY CURRENTLY ARE AUTHORIZED
TO PLAY. I WOULD SUGGEST DON'T
BE FOOLED BY THOSE ARGUMENTS.
CERTAIN NUMBERS OF TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS ABOUT SUIT AGAINST
THE STATE AND CARD CLUBS MAKING
THIS ARGUMENT. THEY HAVE NOT
AVAILED IN THOSE SIX. THIS
MEASURE SIMPLY SURE IS THAT
CARD CLUBS AS WE KNOW THEM
RIGHT NOW CAN CONTINUE TO EXIST.
YOU MAY ALSO HEAR THAT ONLINE
WAGERING WOULD ALLOW MINORS TO
WAGER. HORSE RACING'S TWENTY
YEAR HISTORY OF ONLINE WAGERING
IS PROVEN THAT WALL. THE
TECHNOLOGY EXISTS TO ASSURE
WAGERING OCCURS ONLY BY ADULTS
AND IN FACT IN THE TWENTY YEARS
OF HISTORY THERE HAS NEVER BEEN
AN ALLEGATION MINERS USING THE
INTERNET TO WAGER ON HORSE
RACING. TO SUMMARIZE. A VOTE IN
FAVOR THIS MEASURE HELPS FIRST
AND FOREMOST THE STATE. IT ALSO
HELPS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PROVIDES TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
WITH ADDITIONAL GAMING
OPPORTUNITIES. PROVIDES HORSE
RACING WITH HELP IN THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES AND ALLOWS
CARD CLUBS TO CONTINUE TO EXIST.
IN SOME WAYS THIS MEASURE IS
AND COULD BE A WIN WIN FOR ALL
OF THE VARIOUS ENTITIES
INCLUDING THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. WE DO RESPECT
CONCERNS RAISED BY TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. WE LOOK FORWARD
VERY MUCH TO THE GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS MENTIONED BY BOTH
THE AUTHORS. AND HOPE TO MAKE
THIS MEASURE REALITY IN A WAY
THAT. HAS AN AGREEMENT AND
STRONG SUPPORT BY ALL THE
PARTIES. WITH ME ON THE PHONE
IS CHRIS GROW FROM THE HIGHLY
RESPECTED ECONOMIC FORECASTING
FIRM OF OTHERS AND CRAZY. WHO
WILL SPEAK TO THE SIGNIFICANT
REVENUE NUMBERS THAT THE CITY
CAN EXPECT. AND MISTER
HERNANDEZ CITY MANAGER OF THE
CITY OF ALL AND GARDENS WHO
WILL TESTIFY ON THE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS OF ALLOWING CARD ROOMS
TO BE ELIMINATED. WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK- MISTER
GROW WAS ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU MISTER LAYING. CAN WE CALL
MISTER GROW ON THE PHONE.
MISTER KROEGER LINE IS OPEN
PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT. KRYCEK
GAVE ME A CALIFORNIA BASED
RESEARCH FIRM WHERE I HAD UP
OUR SPORTS BETTING PRACTICE WE
HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
APPEARING PREVIOUSLY IN FRONT
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS OUR RECENT WORK ON THE
CALIFORNIA SPORTS BETTING
QUESTION. I AM SPEAKING TODAY
TO SUMMARIZE OUR LATEST
PROJECTIONS FOR IT LEGAL SPORTS
BETTING IN CALIFORNIA. ARE NOW
OFFICIALLY COMMISSION BY THE
NONPROFIT GROUP YOU KNOW ON THE
GAMBLING POWER GRAB. THE ONLY
INPUT THAT ANGIE PC PROVIDED.
WITH POLICY PARAMETERS AND TIME
FRAME FOR THE ANALYSIS. THE
GROUP OTHERWISE HAD NO INPUT
INTO OR CONTROL OVER OUR FINAL
RESEARCH PROJECT. OUR REPORT
AND ALL OF THE UNDERLYING
MODELS HAVE BEEN MADE AVAILABLE
TO THE COMMITTEE I WILL KEEP MY
TESTIMONY GRIEF AND FOCUSED ON
THREE KEY TAKE AWAYS FROM OUR
ANALYSIS. TAKE AWAY ONE. POLICY
CHOICES IMPACT ILLEGAL SPORTS
BETTING MARKET CAPTURE. OUR
ANALYSIS OF THE STATUS QUO FOR
LEGAL SPORTS BETTING IN THE
UNITED STATES LEADERS TO
CONCLUDE THAT POLICY CHOICES
ESPECIALLY THE QUESTIONS OF
WHETHER OR NOT TO ALLOW ONLINE
SPORTS BETTING AND HOW TO
STRUCTURE TAXES AND FEES PLAY A
MAJOR ROLE IN DETERMINING HOW
MUCH OF THE ILLEGAL MARKET
DEMAND IS CAPTURED BY LEGAL
SPORTS BETTING. THANK YOU
CALIFORNIA'S BETTING MARKET
COULD RAMP UP QUICKLY. THANK
YOU NINA CONDUCIVE TAX AND
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT WE
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
ABILITY TO RAMP UP FASTER THAN
A TYPICAL MARK. THAT MEANS THE
STATE CAN POTENTIALLY REALIZE
MATERIAL SHORT TERM REVENUE
FROM LEGAL SPORTS BETTING
ESPECIALLY VIA UP FRONT LIKE
THE- SPECIFICALLY WE FORECAST
THAT IN THE FIRST SIX MONTHS OF
ACTIVITY. LEGAL SPORTS BETTING
IN CALIFORNIA COULD GENERATE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GROSS GAMING
REVENUES. WHICH WOULD FLOW
THROUGH TO TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
DIRECT TAX AND BE REVENUE TO
THE STATE. THIRD AND FINAL TAKE
AWAY IS THE CLIFORNIA COULD
EASILY BECOME ONE OF THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE THE SPORTS BETTING
MARKETS IN THE WORLD. AGAIN
ENDING A CONDUCIVE ENVIRONMENT
WE BELIEVE THAT THE NEXT OF
CALIFORNIANS DYNAMIC ECONOMY
DEMONSTRATED AFFINITY FOR
GAMBLING A DEEP AND VERY SPORTS
FANDOM AND THE STATE'S FLAGSHIP
STATUS IN THE U. S MARKET
WE'LL ALL CONTRIBUTE TO CREATE
A LEGAL SPORTS BETTING MARKET
THAT STATE IN THE- TOP TIER.
I'M GLOBAL MARKETS ON. AFTER
THE BASIC. SPECIFICALLY WE
FORECAST MARKET MAJORITY LEGAL
SPORTS BETTING IN CALIFORNIA
WILL GENERATE APPROXIMATELY
THREE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN ANNUAL GROSS GAMING REVENUE
FLOWING THROUGH TO
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED AND
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
DIRECT AND TAX REVENUE FOR THE
STATE. WE READILY ADMIT THAT
REASONABLE PEOPLE CAN DISAGREE
ON THE ULTIMATE FIVE OF
CALIFORNIA SPORTS FOR THE
DOCTOR TO. NO ONE IS ARGUING
ABOUT THE AMOUNT CALL INTO THE
NUMBER. GIVEN THE RIGHT POLICY
CONDITIONS THERE IS LITTLE
CREDIBLE DEBATE THAT CALIFORNIA
WILL BE THE LARGEST SPORTS
BETTING MARKET UNITED STATES.
AND ALSO A LITTLE DEBATE THE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BECOME ONE OF THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE MAJOR SPORTS BETTING
MARKETS ON AN ADULT PER CAPITA
BASIS IN THE WORLD. I THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME AND I AM
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
NOW FOR CALLING THIS HEARING.
THANK YOU MISTER GROW. NOW THE
GALLERY BELIEVES WE HAVE MISTER
HERNANDEZ. FOR STATE WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON
AUDIBLE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THERE ANY
HERNANDEZ I AM THE CITY MANAGER
FOR THE CITY OF WEINGARTEN'S
NAME SPEAKING TO IN THAT
CAPACITY. THE CITY IS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY LOCATED
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WITH 77%
LATINO POPULATION. WITH MEDIAN
INCOMES AND EDUCATION LEVELS
ARE LOWER. THAN THE COUNTY AND
STATE AVERAGES. I AM HERE TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT SCA SIX AS A
PROVIDE CERTAINTY. BUT
CONTINUED REVENUES JOBS AND
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY THAT OUR CITY
AND THOSE LIKE. CAN RELY ON TO
CONTINUE TO STRIVE. THE GARDENS
CASINO WHICH HAS OPERATE IN THE
CITY FOR THE PAST TWENTY TWO
YEARS IS A CRITICAL PARTNER TO
THE OUR COMMUNITY. IT HAS
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL IMPACT
AND HAS PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE
IN THE CITY'S ABILITY TO FIGHT
CRIME AND ROLL BACK MAJOR GANG
ISSUES. THE GUARDS CASINO IS
LARGE EMPLOYER IN THE CITY. AND
HAS HELPED TRANSFORM
WEINGARTEN'S COMMUNITY IN A
POSITIVE MANNER. AND PROVIDES
RESIDENTS AND OUR NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES WOULD GOOD PAYING
JOBS AS WELL AS A RESOURCES. TO
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL AND QUALITY
OF LIFE MUNICIPAL SERVICES.
GAMING TAX REVENUES DERIVE FROM
THE GUARDS CASINO MAKE UP OVER
70% OF THE CITY'S GENERAL FUND.
WE SIMPLY CANNOT PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL AND QUALITY OF LIFE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS AT THE
LEVEL WE HAVE NOW WITHOUT THIS
CRITICAL REVENUE SOURCE. AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS WE HAVE
PAINFULLY LEARNED WHAT IT WOULD
BE LIKE WITHOUT THE GARDENS
CASINO AND THE REVENUES THAT
GENERATES. AND I GOT TO TELL
YOU THAT THE HOUSE LOOKS VERY
BLEAK THE CITY HAS ALREADY
ISSUED LAYOFF NOTICES AS IN THE
UNFORTUNATE PROCESS OF
SIGNIFICANT ELIMINATING. AND
ARE REDUCING SERVICES. THE CITY
WILL HAVE TO BALANCE THE KNOWN
LOSSES OF MORE THAN FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR. THE RESERVE FUNDS
AND THE REDUCTION OR
ELIMINATION OF QUALITY OF LIFE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. THESE
KNOWN LOSSES ALREADY REPRESENT
ABOUT 21% OF THE CITY'S BUDGET.
THE REDUCTION ELIMINATION POLLY
LIKE PROGRAMS WILL INCLUDE
SENIOR NEW SERVICES TO INCLUDE
PROGRAMMING TRANSPORTATION AND
EXCURSIONS. YOUTH ACTIVITIES
AND SPORTS NONPROFIT
PARTNERSHIPS. RECREATIONAL
HEALTH AND TECHNOLOGY CLASSES.
AND EVEN ESSENTIAL PROGRAMS
SUCH AS INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS. FURTHER LOSSES
WOULD BE DEVASTATING I COULD
SPELL IT SHUT DOWN OF THE EVEN
ESSENTIAL SERVICES. SUCH AS
IMPACT AND PUBLIC SAFETY AND
COULD EVEN MEAN ON CORPORATION
OF THE CITY AS WE SIMPLY DO NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES. TO PROVIDE
SERVICE. FIRED YOU TO VOTE YES
ON THIS CA SIX TO PRESERVE THE
REVENUES THAT PROVIDE THE JOB
SAFETY AND QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
OUR CAR CLUB CITIES. WITHOUT
YOUR SUPPORT WE ARE DEAD THE
WATERS ORGANIZATION ANY
COMMUNITY TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
IS TO STOP OUR PROGRESS AND
TELL MY CITY OTHERS LIKE IT.
THAT OUR RESIDENTS OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AND OUR EMPLOYEES
THAT WE DON'T MATTER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER HERNANDEZ ARE
THERE ANY. OTHER PEOPLEWHO
WANT TO TESTIFY THAT'S IN THE
GALLERY AT THIS POINT. NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. AS
CHAIR MEMBERS MARIN BEYOND THE
HALF OF THAT CALIFORNIA CITIES
OF SELF RELIANCE JONES POWER
AUTHORITY COMPRISES HE'S OF NO
GUARD COMMON COMPTON CUT A AND
HOW EIGHT PARDONS. WE ECHO
MISTER HERNANDEZ IS- COMMENTS
WE HI THIS OUR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR DESERT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES- WE ARE NOT FOR A
BETTER DREAM AND THE UNITED
STATES. THE CITIES ARE
PROVIDING SUBSTANTIAL SERVICES
TO ACCOMPLISH THOSE DREAMS. WE
CAN'T CONTINUE TO ATTACK CAR
ROOMS WE ALSO ACTUALLY BE
ATTACKING PRICE WHICH WORK
TOGETHER WE ARE LOOKING FOR US
AND WE CAN. GET OUT YES. FOR
ENABLE. THANK YOU SIR. ANY
OTHERS TO TESTIFY AND GALLERY.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTOPHER KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF
THE OAKLAND ATHLETICS AND THE
SAN JOSE EARTHQUAKES
PROFESSIONAL SOCCER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAID MANNING-
WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF THE GARDEN SUCCEED
ONE WILLING SINCE. THANK YOU
SIR. ANYWAY IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO TESTIFY SEEING NONE
AT THIS POINT WE WILL MOVE ON
TO ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TO SEE IF THEY'RE
AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SEE NINE. SEC THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SCA SIX WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THANK YOU
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU GIVE
ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
AND ONCE AGAIN- FOR COMMENTS
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO JUST
A MOMENT MISTER CHAIR.
ABSOLUTELY. IT APPEARS THAT WE
HAVE NO ONE. THE RATE ON MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU ASK ONE FINAL
TIME JUST TO ENSURE. ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
IT A MOMENT IN THEIR LATER
STATING IS PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
GET ON THE LINE RIGHT NOW. THIS
IS.
COULD BE ALL OF YOUR EMAILS.
AND AGAIN MATURE WE APOLOGIZE
FOR THE DELAY JUST ANOTHER
MOMENT PLACE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU.
AND MISTER CHAIR- I'M
GOING TO I'D BE TURNING OVER
THE OPERATIONS TO ANOTHER-
MODERATOR JUST A MOMENT. THANK
YOU.
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY- WE
WILL HAVE THIS RESOLVED SHORTLY
JUST A MOMENT.
WE WILL NOW GO
TO LINE TWELVE ONE TWELVE JERRY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY MAY HAVE
LEFT THE QUEUE WILL NOT GO TELL
WHY ON NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE
TURNED SENATORS CAME ON THE
MCCARTY PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF BEING ONE DOING AND
SEND. WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF US IN
SIX YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TO.
I ONE NOVEL TELL WHY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MISTER. CLOSER
TO CAL EXPO AS ONE OF THE-
INSTITUTIONS OR FACILITY THAT
WOULD BE ALLOWED FOR GAMING- IT
SHOULD. OUR INITIATIVE BECOME
LAW WE HAVE BEEN CONDUCTING
HORSE RACING'S AND EIGHTEEN
FIFTY FOUR SUCCESSFULLY WE ARE
A PUBLIC FACILITY. RECIEVED
DOES FUNDING FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS WOULD PROVIDE A
REVENUE SOURCE SUPPORT OUR
ATHLETES AND EARLY IN THE
PROCESS SURE IN TODAY'S
TESTIMONY THE CHAIR SAYS- SAID
THAT- THEY WANTED TO MAXIMIZE
THE BENEFIT TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE INCLUDING CAL EXPO
WOULD INDEED DO THAT IT WOULD
SUPPORT AN INSTITUTION OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT BADLY
NEEDS THE PUBLIC. SUPPORT IN
THE REVENUE- REMEMBER GRAY ALSO
SAID. THAT THE BILL IN. OUR
RACE BUT SO BUT THAT'S NOT
EXACTLY TRUE. SELECT QUOTE IS
OF COURSE RACING AND IT IS
POINT IS NOT. WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE BE MANY TO ADD HOW
LEX TO THE LANGUAGE AND WITHOUT
WE WOULD SUPPORT. THAT. RIGHT
THEY KEEP YOUR TEST. AND
MODERATOR YOU MOVE ON WE HAVE
TWENTY SEVEN PEOPLE IN THE
QUEUE WAITING TO SPEAK SO I AM
GOING TO ASK SIMPLY FOR YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL AND I
APPRECIATE YOU TO LIMIT
YOURSELF TO THOSE COMMENTS.
MODERATOR PLEASE PROCEED. WELL
NOW CALL LINE A LOT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS AN ACCORD SAYS AND I AM
THE MAYOR FOR THE CITY OF ALL
GARDEN TODAY I AM CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT SIX
PROTECTING CARD ROOMS PROTECT
LOW INCOME COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF
THE SERVICES THAT HELP TO
PROVIDE. COMMITTEE TODAY
REFLECT. THE BORDER ON THE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOU TO.
WELL NOT BOTTOM LINE SIXTY FIVE
WHAT AIRLINE AND WALDRON. GO IN
ARE YOU FROM SEE A MAJOR IN
CANADA WE ARE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR YOU TO. HELLO NOT A
CALL TILL NINE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS MY
NAME IS SPENCER DELA CRUZ AND I
AM THE MANAGER OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT REPRESENTING THE
CITY OF GARDENA ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
BILL NUMBER. AT EIGHTY EIGHT
SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. HELLO NEXT COURT CAROLINA
ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU GREG- THIS IS
GREG SHERIFF SHERMAN FEDERATED
INDIAN GRATON RANCHERIA TRAVEL
MEMBERS ONE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT. I
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE. SIX RIGHT
THANK YOU. ONE ALL COME FOR
FOUR YEAR LINE AND OPEN. HE
MIGHT BE NEAR THEIR FORTY YOUR
LINE OF OPEN. THE LOS THE
CONGRESS CASINO OPENS. THANK
SIR. I WILL NOW GO TO NINE FOUR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS
IS PATRICK VERY GENERAL MANAGER
PLAYERS CASINO AND ENTER A
CALIFORNIA. BOARD OF DIRECTORS
CALIFORNIA GAME ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER BERRY.
WELL NOW CALLED HOME NINE
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND SENATORS MY
NAME IS COOLEY FEEL CITY OF
COMPTON LOCAL PRESIDENT AND
DISTRICTS FOR VICE PRESIDENT
WOULD ASK ME AND I AM CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I HELLO NOVEL
TIMELINE SEVENTY HERE LINE IS
NOW OPEN PEOPLE I HAD. HELLO
TRANSCEND MY NAME'S JOKES I'M
AN EXACT DIRECTOR OF THE POWER
GAMING SAYS. THE REPRESENTED
MAJORITY THE STATE'S CARD ROOMS
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE-
THANK YOU. WELL NOT ALL AFFORD
NINE HERE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
CALL I HAD. CITY MANAGER AT
CHRISTMAS. SUPPORT SCA SIX
THANK YOU THE YOU. WHAT ARE NOW
CALLED CAROLINE AT NIGHT PM
YOUR LINE ITSELF YOU CALL I HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON IS CHRIS BOY THE
CITY MANAGER FOR THE SAME OF
CITRUS. THE CITY OF CITRUS
HEIGHTS IS A THE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WELL NOT ALL
CAROLINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE
OF THE- YOU'VE GOT. RONALD LARA
IMMEDIATE BASS PRO CAL POLICE
CHIEFS. AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SCA SIX. THANK YOU.
WELL NOT ALL THE TIME LINE ONE
NOTE THAT IN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NATURE OF
MY NAME IS REALLY BEEN JUST SO
I AMTHE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA CITIES GAINING
AUTHORITY. A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY. THE CCG A WAS FORMED
TO PROTECT THE INTERESTS OF
SIXTY THREE CITIES STATEWIDE
WITH SMALL AND MEDIUM CARD
ROOMS LICENSE CARD ROOM SINCE
RESIDENTS. LOCAL BUSINESSES.
AND THEIR EMPLOYEES THIS THE
PASSAGE OF. CA SIX IS VITAL TO
THE FISCAL RECOVERY OF OUR
CITIES WITH CARD ROOMS. THOSE
CITIES BUDGET HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED. BECAUSE OF THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND ARE
STRUGGLING TO PROVIDE THE BASIC
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS LIKE
PARAMEDICS FIRE INCLUDES AMPLY
SERVICES WE ARE JUNE AND ALL
THE MEMBERS THIS VOTE YES ON
INTERNET CA SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY MA
MODERATOR BEFORE YOU CONTINUE I
WANT TO REMIND OUR WITNESSES T
THIS POINT. IN THE TESTIMONY
YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND
WHETHER OR NOT YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL HI AGAIN I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU WOULD
CONFINE YOURSELF TO THOSE
COMMENTS THANK YOU. YOU WILL
NOT HOLD TIMELINE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MRS MEYER FROM A RAW
WORK THIRD PARTY PROVIDER IN
ONE'S OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SIR. WELL NOT ALL THE TIME AND
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHANE DUSTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS AND
GOLDEN BEAR RACINE I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE KEY SUPPORTERS OF THE
BILL FOR WORKING WITH US TO
INCLUDE SACRAMENTO AND- WITH
THAT AGREEMENT WE SUPPORT
DOUBLE BILL STILL PULLING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. WELL I'M
NOT GONNA LINE AT ONE OO TO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. BUT THIS
IS ALSO A MEASURE OF THIS
COUNCIL MEMBER MIKE DEALS WITH
CITY JEWEL THE FIVE STRONG
SUPPORT. SO YOU HAD TO GET A-
THANK SIR. WELL NOT GONNA
CAROLINE THIRTY YEARS AGO I HAD.
THIS IS JOHN LEVEL LET THE
WHOLE OF LAWN BOARD THE WE COME
QUITE AGREE WITH GERMAN DODD
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT THE OF
BRINGING SUPPORT OUT OF THE
SHADOWS. THAT'S A SENTIMENT
SHARED BY THE BALLOT NINE
PRODUCT OFFICE ASSOCIATION THE
COALITION OF PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS SUPPORT SYSTEMS
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE UNIVERSITY
COLLEAGUES JAMES CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISORS ARE
GOING TO SAY AND THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT LIST WILL CONTINUE
TO GROW AND GROW AND GROW AND.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THEIR-
THANK YOU SIR. WELL NEXT GONNA
TELL LINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SORTIE OF
RACING FAIRS WE HAVE A SUPPORT
IF AMENDED POSITION AND ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE AND CAL
EXPO BUT WOULD EXPAND THAT TO
INCLUDE ALL RAISING FARES. FOR
THE EQUITY AND TO EXPAND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BROWN. ONE I GO TO LINE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE CALL I HAD.
JOHN SORIA COUNCILMEMBER
REPRESENTED THE CITY OF
COMMERCE HOME TO THE COMMERCE
CASINO AS WELL AS A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR SELF
RELIANCE GPA REPRESENTED
RESPECTIVE INTERESTS OF CARMEN
COMMUNITIES TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF COMMERCE OF STATURE
AND REACH AFFORD. F. C. EIGHTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
ACT BOTTOM LINE AT ONE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE CALL I HAD. YES
HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS GOT WHICH HE HAPPENED
CIVIC RACING ASSOCIATION. THE
LOS ANGELES BIRTH CLUB WE
SUPPORT AND SEE EIGHTY SIX
MOVIE FOR TODAY HOWEVER WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS REGARDING THE
CARD ROOM PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SIR. ONE AT A TIME LINE.
NINE PLEASE CALL HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS MARK JOSEPH
COUNCILMEMBER OF THE CITY OF
AMERICAN CANYON AND I SUPPORT
SCA SIX BECAUSE I WANT TO
PROTECT OUR LOCAL CARD ROOM THE
NAPA DELICACY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. ONE I CALLED TO LINE
NINETY PEOPLE I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE ENGINE MINETTI HERE
AND THE CORE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY RIGHT NOW AND A LOS
ANGELES FOOTBALL CLUB. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. HELLO
NEXT TO LINE AND NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS THIS
IS JOE GALVEZ DEPUTY MAYOR OF
THE CITY WILL OF THE THAT
EXPECTING OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR AND HE EIGHTY SIX BECAUSE
OF THE PROVISIONS THAT WILL
PROVIDE CONSTITUTIONALITY
UNCERTAINTY. ROOM TO KEEP
PLAYING THE GAME THE COMPLAINT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
HELLO MICHAEL ONLINE AT ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS GREG CAMPBELL ON BEHALF
OF MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL THE
NATIONAL BASKETBALL ASSOCIATION
IN THE PGA TOUR IN SUPPORT OF
SCA SIX THANK YOU MISTER
CAMPBELL. ON I GOTTA TELL LINE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JUSTIN
QUIZ QUIZZES BUT Q. U. I. S. Q.
U. I. S. SOME VICE CHAIRMAN OF
THE SAM'S CLUB AND A MISSION
INDIANS AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
WE HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY
TRAVEL MEMBER AND DOZENS OF
FAMILIES A WORK FOR THE TRIBE
WITHIN OUR VARIOUS BUSINESSES
AND SAMPLES STRONGLY OPPOSES
STA SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR TESTIMONY. WELL IN THAT
BOTTOM LINE AT ONE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MICHAEL KELLY OF THE CITY
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF BELL
GARDENS SOME OF THE BICYCLE
HOTEL CASINO. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. STILL ON MY PHOTO A
ONE FOUR LEAVE SCHOOL I. THIS
IS A CISCO GET AFTERNOON. WE'RE
JUST OF ENTRY INTO YOUR COACH
TO LOSE OF. SEE BASICS THANK
YOU AT THE YOU. HELLO MY GOT TO
LINE UP THIRTY. PLEASE HAD. HI
THIS IS KYLE KIRK THE FOR HELP
GAME IS. FIVE OH ONE SIX
STRAIGHT SO SHE THE WRECK CAL
CAR AND- MARK STRONG SUPPORT OF.
THE EIGHT YEAR. ALL THE WORKERS
DONE GRANTED THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ONE NIGHT GO TO ALLOW AT
ONE THIRTY EIGHT PEOPLE I HAD.
REGARD FOR CHRISTMAS CRYSTAL
YOU KNOW IN OCEAN'S ELEVEN
CASINO WHAT IS GOING TO COURT.
THANK YOU SIR. MONACO LINE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE CALL I HAD.
WHAT IS GOING TO PAY FOR THE
QUEEN A BAND OF INDIANS BOARD
OF DIRECTORS FOR THE QUEEN
CRISTINA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
SIX. THANK YOU. AND THEN I GET
A VERY MINOR KEY SHOW AT THE
PORT OF THE BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN THERE OUGHT THIS
TIME LONDON FERAL HE SHOWS THE
PORT. LITTLE CULTURE THE LINE
NUMBER TWELVE PLEASE CALL I HAD.
LINE TWO OF YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE WILL NOT LOOKING ONLINE WHAT
I'M TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWELVE AIRLINERS OPEN. ALRIGHT
WE'LL AND I GO TO LINE AT ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CHAIR BLONDE IN ON THE
APPLICATION AT THE CASINO
CAPITAL CASINO CASINO MADERA
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE TIME.
MODERATOR MAY YOU- ONE MORE
TIME CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY THERE IN SUPPORT AT SCA
SIX. YEAH AND AS A REMINDER TO
SHOW SUPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN AS A REMINDER TO SHELVE
THE POOR OF THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEY'RE ALL AT THAT
TIME. IMMEDIATE TO HAVE ABOUT
FOUR IN THE QUEUE LOCAL ONLINE
ONE OO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR MY NAME VERY
FISHER ON THE DEPUTY PICKING
FOR THE OF VENTURA THE CITY OF
VENTURA STRONGLY SUPPORTS THAT
THE EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND ON THAT GOAL TO LINE NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SORRY I
THEIR MINDS ALREADY THANK YOU.
THE NEXT LEVEL TIMELINE AT ONE
TWELVE WE'VE HAD. WHY NO ONE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU
MAY HAVE THE ON YOUR ON YOUR
SIDE. SHOULDN'T ACTUAL A TIME
LINE TWELVE. HELLO ALREADY
LEARNING THEIR MEMBERS. WE CAN
AREA. THANK YOU OUR MILITARY
MEMBER DODD AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS LUCY COLOMBO
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AT EIGHT
THIRTY. AND WE ASK YOU TO VOTE
YEAH. OUR LOCAL PARK CLUB AND
HELP SAVE OUR CITIES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. WE HAD
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. AT THE MOMENT
CAN YOU ASK ONE FINAL TIME
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SCA SIX AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE OTHER SIDE.
YES I CAN. VERY MINDER TO SHOW
THE POWER OF THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEY'RE ALL AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN HE SHOWED THE
POOR OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEY'RE ALL AT THAT TIME.
WELL NOT GOAL CAN LINE AT ONE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHOWING
LINE TWENTY THREE IS THIS ONE
TWELVE BE ACTED AS WELL RIGHT
WHY LINE SAYS MIKE BONE SHOWS
LINE TWENTY THREE THERE WAS MY
NAME'S KERMIT SHELTER WAS
STONE'S GAMBLING ALL IN CITRUS
HEIGHTS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE ON THIS. WE ARE A SMALL
CLUB- CITRUS HEIGHTS PROVIDE
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED LIVING
WAGE JOBS THE CITY'S CITRUS
HEIGHTS AND WE'RE IN TRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU. WELL IN THAT GOAL COOL
MINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE AHEAD.
SUPPORT VENTURE PICKING THE. IT
DID THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. PROTECTION CHAU. WE
HAVE NO AND I AND Q. AT THE
MOMENT OKAY MODERATOR I'M GOING
TO ASK YOU ONE FINAL TIME TO
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
SUPPORT AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON
TO THE OPPOSITION. AND AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT OF THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS. TIME AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORTER OF THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE. THE GIRL AT THAT
TIME. AND WE HAD NO ONE THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
MODERATOR SO IF THERE'S NO MORE
WITNESSES. AND HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN
HERE FROM ANY OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE CHAIRMAN JEFF- GROOVY
AND JEFF BUTLER ARE ON THE
PHONE AS A PRIMARY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. YES THIS IS CHAIRMAN
GROOVY ON MY YOU CAN HEAR ME
YES SIR. OKAY GOOD- GOOD
AFTERNOON- GERMAN DODD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI THIS IS
GERMAN GROOVY. OF THE ALL WHEEL
CALLING TECH BANDIT QUEEN BEES
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE G.
O. COMMITTEE. WE TRY TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF THE LIMITED TIME
GIVEN TO US FOR BY TESTIMONY
OBVIOUSLY WE COULD SPEND FAR
MORE THAN TEN MINUTES ON THIS.
WE HAVE SEVERAL TRIBAL CHAIRS
CALLING AN EXPLOSIVE SERIOUS
OPPOSITION OF THEIR SOVEREIGN
TRIBES AS THE ASICS I'M
CONFIDENT YOU'LL HEAR DIRECTLY
FROM THEM. AFTER SEEING HIS
PROPOSED CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT FOR THE FIRST TIME
LAST THURSDAY. AND LEARNING OF
THIS QUICKLY SCHEDULED HEARING
LAST FRIDAY. I DID TRY TO GET
IN CONTACT WITH CHAIRMAN DODD
ANY IN OUR EXPRESSED MY
CONCERNS AND ISSUES WITH HIM
DIRECTLY SO THERE'S WON'T BE
ANY SURPRISE TO HIM. AND I
BELIEVE THAT. WE ARE NOT THE
ONLY TRIED IN FACT I DON'T EVEN
TRY IT WILL APPROVE. SB. EIGHTY
SIX. SB EIGHTY SIX ALL. SPORTS
WAGERING TO TRY TO GOVERNMENT
AND- EXTRA SAY IN THE TRI TO
TRY. ARE THE BEST WHICH IS T.
TO A- AS HEIDI BY. I NOTING
DECADES OF THE- AND PLAN.
RESOURCES WE AGREE WITH. SCA
HOW TRIBE GOV. EXPERTISE IN
RIGHT. OPERATE BUT ALSO NO
TROUBLE GOVERNMENT CONTRIBUTION
TO THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN BECAUSE
HER BODY OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND JOBS
TWENTY BILLION AND ECONOMIC
OUTPUT NINE BILLION EMPLOYEE
WAGES. AND THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION IN THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALL FROM LEGAL.
GAMING. REVENUES LEGAL. THAT'S
CA SIX REGULAR YOU CAN GREAT
THING THE TRIBE YOU DOOR BUT
THE SAME TIME IT A MAN'S CAL
CON. STRIP AWAY THE EXCLUSIVE
RIGHT A TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS TO
OFFERED PRE GAMES THERE ARE
CONTACTS YOU CURED WITH THE
PASSAGE OF PROP ONE EIGHT. SHE
A SIXGIVE THE RIGHT THE CARD
ROOMS TO OPERATE ILLEGAL BANK
GAMES IN PLAIN SIGHT GENERATED
REVENUES THAT RIGHTFULLY SHOULD
QUOTA TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS IN VIA
OUR CONTACT. ULTIMATELY FLOWING
BACK TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
NON GAMING TRIBES WHY DID THE
SPORTS WAGERING BILL CONTAINED
A GIFT TO BRING GAMES. THE CARD
ROOM INDUSTRY WHOSE ENTIRE
BUSINESS MODEL IS BUILT AROUND
SIR COMPETING CALIFORNIA LAW
FOR ITS OWN BENEFIT AND THE
DIRECT EXPERIENCE OF TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. YOU TALKED ABOUT
NOT HAVING A SOLUTION OR TRYING
TO COME TO A SOLUTION BETWEEN
CARD ROOMS AND TRIES TO
SOLUTION SIMPLE CARGO SHIP GAME
LEGALLY NOT CIRCUMVENT THE LAW.
WHY DO WHY DID OF SPORTS
WAGERING BUILT. IT REWARDS ARE
COURTROOM INDUSTRY WERE SERIOUS
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY MAJOR
VIOLATIONS OF STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW OR ON COVERED WITH ALARMING
REGULARITY INTENTIONALLY LOW
EXPRESSING CONCERNS ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY OF SPORTS WAGERING
THAT PROTECTION OF CONSUMERS
FROM SHADIA LEGAL SPORTS
WAGERING OPERATORS FTA SIX
AUTHORIZES ONLINE SPORTS
WAGERING. ON MARCH FOURTH
WAGERING RAISES MANY REGULATORY
CHALLENGES INCLUDING HOW TO
IDENTIFY PREVENT MINORS FROM
GAMBLING HOW TO IDENTIFY MISSUS
PROBLEM GAMBLERS AND HOW TO
EFFECTIVELY POLICE AGAINST
UNAUTHORIZED AT THE STATION
TRANSACTIONS WITHOUT DIRECT
INTERACTION WITH TRAINED GAMING
FACILITIES STAFF IF YOU ARE
TRULY CONCERNED ABOUT STRONG
AND EFFECTIVE SPORTS WAGERING
REGULATIONS. IN AUTHORIZED
BEING ONLINE SPORTS WAGERING
SEEMS LIKE A POOR TOWARDS THE
FTA SIX FACT SHEET CONTAINS TAX
ESTIMATES THAT APPEARED TO BE
COULD BARELY OVERESTIMATED
ESPECIALLY IN THE SCOLDED
NINETEEN ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT
WHAT CALIFORNIANS HAVE LIMITED
DISPOSAL INCOME. TAX REVENUE
GENERATED FROM THESE MEASURES
WILL HAVE NO MEANINGFUL IMPACT
ON THE. MASSIVE BUDGET DEFICIT.
WELL BREAK A MORE. FORTY DURING
HIS AUTHOR NUTRITIONAL ONLINE
WAGERING WORKS LIKE THE OF
BRICK AND MORTAR SO TO PROTECT
THEIR INVESTMENT AND CREATE
CALIFORNIA JOBS IT APPEARS THAT
ARE OUT OF STATE SPORTS WE OUT
OF STATE SPORTS WAGERING
PLATFORMS WILL BE THE BIG
WINNERS SB SIX. BECOMES LAW FOR
THESE REASONS AND MANY MORE AS
NOTED ARE OPPOSITION LETTER WE
ASK YOU CHAIRMAN DODD TO
WITHDRAW SCA SIX THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
GROOVY DO WE HAVE MISTER JEFF
FATHER ON THE PHONE. TELL YOUR
PRESENT OKAY. OUR MODERATOR
HE'S ACTUALLY IN THE GALLERY.
GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN%
DIED IN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JEFF BUTLER I AM A
PARTNER IN THE LAW FIRM OF
DENTON'S U. S. L. O. P. AND
REPRESENT THE YORKSHIRE D. HE
WENT TO NATION. DUE TO THE
LIMITATION OF THE NUMBER
SPEAKERS TODAY HOWEVER. I SPEAK
NOT ONLY ON BEHALF. OF YOUR
CITY. FOR MORE BROADLY FOR
VARIOUS. TRIBES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA INDIAN COUNTRY. MY
FIRST ONE EXPLAIN THAT WHAT IS
CA SIX DOES IS LEGALIZE
PATENTLY ILLEGAL CONDUCT.
CARTER'S LIKE TO SAY THEIR%
GAMES ARE PERFECTLY LEGAL AND
INDEED THE SCA SIX FACT SHEET
CLAIMS THE MEASUREWOULD ALLOW
CARD ROOMS TO CONTINUE TO PLAY
THE GAMES THEY ARE CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED TO PLAY. NEITHER
STAY IS TRUE. MOST OBVIOUS IF
CARD ROOMS ARE ALREADY
AUTHORIZED TO PLAY THOSE GAMES
NO CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
WOULD BE NEEDED. SO HOW ARE
THOSE GAMES ILLEGAL. PENAL CODE
SECTION THREE THREE ZERO
PROHIBITS BANK GAMES PLAYED
WITH CARDS. A BANK GAME HAPPENS
WHEN ONE PLAYER ACCESS  BANK
TAKING ON ALL COMERS PAIN
WINTERS I COLLECTING FROM
LOSERS. THAT PROBATION HAS
EXISTED IN CALIFORNIA SINCE AT
LEAST EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO I
WAS RAISED TO A CONSTITUTIONAL
LEVEL IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
WHEN THE CONSTITUTION WAS
AMENDED TO PREFER GAMES LIKE
THOSE PLAYED IN THE BOTTOM AND
TO JERSEY. AN EXAMPLE OF THESE
PROHIBIT GAMES AS A BLACKJACK
YOU WOULD SEE IN A LAS VEGAS OR
INDIAN CASINO. WHERE YOU PLAY
AGAINST THE DEALER. CALIFORNIA
LAW HAS ANOTHER MUCH NEWER
PROVISION PENAL CODE SECTION
THREE THREE ZERO POINT ONE ONE.
THIS IS A GAME IS NOT BANK. IF
THE BANKER POSITION ROTATES
CONTINUOUSLY AMONG THE PLAYERS.
THAT MEANS THOSE GAMES CAN BE
PLAYED AND CARD ROOMS IF BUT
ONLY IF THE BANKER POSITION
MOVED ALL THE TIME BETWEEN THE
PLAYERS PREVENTING ANY ONE OF
THEM. FROM ACTING AS A BANK. I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF YOU. I'VE
BEEN TO A LOCAL CAR ROOM BUT
THE CARD GAMES PLAYED THERE ARE
EXACTLY LIKE THOSE PLAYED IN
LAS VEGAS OR INDIAN CASINOS
THERE'S NO ROTATION OF THE
PLAYER DEALER POSITION AMONG
THE PLAYERS AT THE TABLE. AS A
PENAL CODE REQUIRES. THE PERSON
ACTING AS A BANK IN A CAR ROOMS
CALLED A THIRD PARTY
PROPOSITION PLAYER. OR PERHAPS
YOU'VE HEARD OF THE TERM TPP
WHICH IS A SHORTHAND FOR THAT.
THANK YOU MIGHT WONDER. IF THE
LAW IS THAT CLEAR. HOW DID THE
CARD ROOMS GET AROUND THE IRON
CLAD PROHIBITION. AGAINST BANK
GAINES. THE ANSWER IS THROUGH
AN INFAMOUS DOCUMENT KNOWN. AS
THE LYTLE LETTER. ROBERT LYTLE
WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE STATE'S
BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL THE
AGENCY THAT REGULATES CARBS. ON
DECEMBER TWENTY OF TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVEN LYELL WROTE TO THE
PRESIDENTS OF TWO GROUPS
LOBBYING FOR CARDS. IN THAT
LETTER LYTLE IN HIS OFFICIAL
CAPACITY SAID THE PENAL CODE
SECTION THREE THREE ZERO POINT
ONE ONE. DID NOT REQUIRE ACTUAL
ROTATION OF THE BANKER POSITION
BUT ONLY THE OFFER. OF THAT
POSITION TO THE OTHER PLAYERS
AT THE TABLE. THERE WERE TWO
PROBLEMS WITH THE LIGHT LETTER
FIRST IT CONTRADICTED THE LAW.
THE SECOND PROBLEM WAS IS
PROVIDENCE. TEN DAYS AFTER
ISSUING THE LETTER MR LYTLE
WENT TO WORK FOR A CORPORATE.
IN DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THE BUREAU LINES
FORMER EMPLOYER. FILED A FORMAL
ACCUSATION AGAINST HIM ALLEGING
HE NEGOTIATED FOR THAT CARD
ROOM JOB BEFORE HE LEFT THE
BUREAU AND THEREFORE BEFORE HE
ISSUED THE LETTER. THE BUREAU
CONCLUDED THAT LYTLE ACTED AND
I'M QUOTING HERE FOR PERSONAL
GAIN AND THE GAME OF THOSE WHOM
HE CAME TO REPRESENT. THAT HE
ABANDONED THE BASIC PRINCIPLES
OF THE STATE AGENCY AND THE
GENERAL PUBLIC THAT HE SERVED.
AND THAT HE IS NOT A PERSON OF
GOOD CHARACTER. HONESTY AND
INTEGRITY. THROUGH JULY TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SETTLEMENT OF
THE ACCUSATION LYTLE WAS
STRIPPED OF HIS GAME LICENSES
HE ADMITTED HE WASN'T QUALIFIED
FOR BUREAU LICENSURE AND AGREE
TO A LIFETIME BAN. IN ALSO
AGREED TO PAY A SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE. NO THIS
ISN'T JUST THE TRIBES
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW. OR
THE FACTS HERE. ON DECEMBER
THIRD OF LAST YEAR THE BUREAU
ISSUED CONCEPT REGULATORY
LANGUAGE THAT IS SPECIFICALLY
INTENDED TO FORCE THE ROTATION.
OF THE PLAYER DEALER POSITION.
EVERY TWO HANDS. LESS OBVIOUSLY
IT TOURNEY GENERAL AGREES THE
LIGHT LETTER IS WRONG ON THE
LAW. NOW LET'S TURN BACK TO SCA
SIX IN AMENDMENT NINE THE
MEASURE PROVIDES THAT
NOTWITHSTANDING ANY OTHER
PROVISION OF STATE LAW. LAYERS
IN CAR ROOMS ARE ALLOWED TO
WAGER AGAINST EACH OTHER. WHICH
MEANS THAT HE BANKING GAME DOES
NOT INCLUDE THE SITUATION WHERE
THE PLAYER DEALER WAGERS
AGAINST THE OTHER PARTICIPANTS
PROVIDED THAT EACH PARTICIPANT
IS OFFERED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE THE PLAYER DEALING. STATED
MORE STARKLY SCA SIX HITS WHAT
YOU MIGHT CALL A TRY FACTOR IF
YOU'LL PARDON THE PUN. ONE
ILLEGITIMACY IS PATENTLY
ILLEGAL CONDUCT AND IN DOING SO
OVERTURNS NEARLY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY YEARS OF PROHIBITION IN
THE PENAL CODE AGAINST BANK
GAMES AS WELL AS A
CONSTITUTIONAL BAN. ON SUCH
GAMES. TO IT WIPES OUT ATTORNEY
GENERAL BESET US CURRENT
EFFORTS TO FORCE THE CARD ROOMS
TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW THERE BY
REWARDING ENTITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN VIOLATING THE LAW FOR MANY
YEARS. AND THREE CONSTITUTIONAL
LIES'S THE LYTLE LETTERS SORTED
OFFER STANDARD. NONE OF THOSE
ACTIONS IS APPROPRIATE FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY OF THIS GREAT
STATE. I WANT TO FOLLOW UP WITH
WAR HELLO FEW MORE SPECIFICS ON
AN ISSUE THE CHAIRMAN GROOVY
RACE THE VERY REAL CONCERN
ABOUT EXPANDING THE GAMING
RIGHTS. OF A SEGMENT OF THE
GAMING INDUSTRY THAT IS
DEMONSTRATED EXCEEDINGLY
SERIOUS REGULATORY PROBLEMS LET
ME SAY JUST TWO RECENT EXAMPLES
OF MANY AND THEY ARE MANY AND
WITH APOLOGIES TO THE GENTLEMAN
WHO THE CITY MANAGER OF THE-
CITY OF HAWAIIAN GARDEN SO
WE'LL START THERE. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN FINSEN THE
FINANCIAL CRIMES ENFORCEMENT
NETWORK. WHICH IS PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE TREASURY FINE
THE GUARDS CASINO IN
WEINGARTEN'S TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A QUOTE
REPEATED ANTI MONEY LAUNDERING
VIOLATIONS OVER A PERIOD OF
YEARS. IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO
THAT SAME CARD ROOM WAS FIND
ANOTHER THREE POINT ONE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS BY THE STATE'S
BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL FOR
FAILING TO DISCLOSE THE FINS
INVESTIGATION RESULTING FINE.
IN NOVEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
FINSEN FIND ARTICHOKE JOE'S
CARD ROOM EIGHT MILLION FOR
WOOD FENCING CALLED. WILLFUL
VIOLATION OF ANTI MONEY
LAUNDERING CONTROLS INCLUDING
TURNING IN A QUOTE HERE AGAIN.
A BLIND EYE TO LOAN SHARKING
SUSPICIOUS HIGH VALUE CHIP
TRANSFERS AND FLAGRANT CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY FOR YEARS. WELL
THERE'S MUCH MORE THAT WE COULD
SAY ABOUT SCA SIX WE HAVE
LIMITED TIME SO CLOSE HERE I
URGE YOU. TO WITHDRAW SCA SIX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
BUTLER AT THIS TIME WE'LL MOVE
ON TO OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY AND AT THIS POINT. ITS
NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE WE WILL MOVE ON TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE. WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THOSE THAT
WANT TO TESTIFY INDIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SCA
SIX WE WILL BEGIN. YOU OPPOSE
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS WINE AND
THEY'RE ALL AT THIS TIME AGAIN
YOU OPPOSED THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE THEY'RE ALL AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE DEPRESSED
LINES THEY'RE ALL AND YOU DID
NOT A POLL OF THE OF THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE IS THEIR OLD
TO REMOVE YOURSELF AGAIN THIS
IS A FEW OF THE HOLES OF THE
BELT PLEASE PRESS. ONE THEY'RE
ALL AT THIS TIME. IT WILL GO TO
LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IT IS DONE THE LOGO TERM BURKE
WE'VE BEEN TO BEGIN I JUST LIKE
TO SAY THANK YOU CORD- AND
TAKING THE TIME TO YEARS TODAY
BUT WE ARE STRONG OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL- AS WE DISCUSSED.
LAST YEAR WE CAME UP AND TALKED
TO NUMEROUS LEGISLATORS UP
THERE IN THE CAPITAL EVERYONE
AGREED MANY OF THEM AGREED AND
TOLD US THEY UNDERSTOOD AS A
LOT OF ILLEGAL ACTIVITY GOING
ON ALLOW. ALLOW QUIRK- THE
LICCARDO. I THE GENERAL. TO
ADDRESS IT AND WE DID IT WE
WORK. BUT THEN THIS COMES UP
AND ALL THE SUDDEN YOU KNOW
THIS IS A COMPLETE CHANGE YOU
KNOW AND TO SAY THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH DRIVERS. EVER
HEARD ONE YET ONE TRIBE. BOARDS
AS WE TOLD IT LAST YEAR THAT
YOU'RE GONNA WORK WITH THAT.
INTEL IS THAT RIGHT YEAH YEAH
YOU'LL GIVE IT TIME YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO WEAR WORKS OF
MATH. WOULDN'T SHOULD NOT EVEN
BE ANYTHING IT'S- A COMPLETELY
DISRESPECTFUL REQUESTING.
ESPECIALLY DURING A TIME. OF
WHEN WE ARE IN GREAT NEED IN
THEIR STORES YOU KNOW JUST AS
THE- EARLIER. I'M GOING UP AND
DOWN HARD BE DOING THE SAME
EXACT THING YOU'RE EXPERIENCING
THE SAME ACTING SO- DUE TO
FURTHER I GET- BECAUSE THE MIND
TO THEIR ECONOMY BY TRYING TO
STRIP AWAY- GAINING- IT JUST
ISN'T RIGHT DEFINITELY NOT THE
RIGHT TIME YOU KNOW TO BRING
CALIFORNIA TRIED TO BEING
SUCCESSFUL ALL OF THEM BEING
SUCCESSFUL OR NOT BUT ALL OF
THEM THERE'S A COUPLE BUT YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF TRIBES
WHICH IS WHO WE ARE THAT JUST
BARELY GETTING INTO THE MARKET
AND TO CHANGE THE WORLD ON A-
AND YOUR INTRODUCE THIS NEW
FORGET. YOU KNOWAND WITHOUT
CONSULTATION TO TRY IT'S JUST
RIDICULOUS YOU KNOW IT'S JUST
GONNA PORTIONS. GO BACK INTO. I
WILL DRIVE NAY GOING BACK INTO
THEIR OWN STATIONS BUT WHO
CARES ABOUT THE- YOU KNOW.
EIGHT INCLUDE ONLY FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR TRIBE MEMBERS WHO
TRAVEL MEMBERS AND- YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW. WE'RE NEAR CONNECTION
I ALWAYS EXPRESSED THAT WE'RE
NEAR EXTINCTION. AND SO YOU
KNOW. I WOULD. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU GUYS YOU KNOW YOU
GUYS WALKING THE CAN DOWN THE
CAPITAL HOLD ALL DAY LONG- WHEN
YOU SEE THAT BEARD RIGHT THERE
ON THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. YOU
KNOW THAT BUTTON. THAT YOU GUYS
COULD PROVIDE. YOU KNOW THE
EXTENSION TEN. BY DOING THESE
KIND OF MEASURES. IN THE DARK
YOU KNOW. THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE GOING TO TRADE NO THAT'S
WHAT YOU. THAT'S THE LEGACY
THAT YOU GUYS EVER LEAVE. SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU GUYS. TO
WITHDRAW THIS BILL YOU KNOW AND
THAT YOU WORK WITH TRIBES
REALLY WORKER TRIED. AND. NOT
JUST MAKE IT AS A- THANK YOU
MISTER. OF MY- BEFORE WE MOVE
ON I WON TO REMIND US THAT
GOING TO TESTIFY AT THIS POINT.
ITS NAME AFFILIATION AND THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AMID A
MODERATOR YOU MAY PROCEED. I
HAD A LOT TO LINE AT ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- DAN LITTLE WITH THE
FAMILY WHILE BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SCA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
LITTLE. I'M ON THAT CALL UP TO
THE LINE OF ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. FREE TO LEAVE
I'LL BE HAPPY TO SEND YOU THIS
BRAND OF SHOE MISSION IS ALSO
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT COURT
TIMELINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE CALL
I HAD. REVENUES FROM THE
NUMBERS MY NAME IS MIKE LOPEZ I
AM THE VICE CHAIRMAN OF SCENE I
GUESS CALIFORNIA NATION IN
GAMES OF THE SEASON UNITED
THIRTY FIVE TRIBAL GOVERNMENT
STRONGLY OPPOSE SCA SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. I KNOW I'M
NOT GO TO LINE AT ONE THIRTY
PLEASE CALL I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS FRED JONES
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
AGAINST GAMBLING EXPANSION
DATABASE BASED ORGANIZATION IN
STRONG POSITION TO THIS.
RADICAL EXPANSION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. BOTTOM LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD THANK YOU MY NAME IS
AFFECT MARKETS OF CREATURE
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF THE TO
THE RIVER TRIBE ME ACCURATE
CENTRAL VALLEY THE TRIBE AS
OPPOSED TO SCA SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MARCUS. WHEN I
GO TO LINE SEVENTY EIGHT
CRITICAL I HAD. YEAH DAVID KING
KHAN ON BEHALF OF THE BAND- MAY
I INDIAN AND ABOUT THE WHOLE
POMO BUT UPPER LAKE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. ONE AT A TIME LINE
AT ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BELOW MARKET CARL JR THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JUG BAND OF THE
SENATE ANY OF THEM POINT NEARLY
WITHOUT THE CALIFORNIANS. MORE
THAN NINETEEN CRANKY TIGHTENING
OF MOVING THIS BILL AT THE APEX
DURING THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE ONLY. ENERGY IS A
SUCKER PUNCH TO IT WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THAT'S THE EIGHT SIX
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE
FATTEST FOUND GAME THE CARD THE
AND EFFECTIVELY WITH. EXCLUSIVE
GAMING RIGHT THE THIRD FOR
CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBE BY 65%
OF THE VOTERS IN MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND PROPOSITION ONE EIGHT.
WE WILL NOT COMPROMISE AND
THERE WAS NO ROOM TO DEAL ON
OUR- GAMING RIGHT AND THAT'S
WITH BILL FOR COURTS TO DO FOR
THE CARD WE GOT IT. WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU MISTER.
CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. TO
LEARN THAT TO LINE A ONE. LEAVE
GO AHEAD. YEAH CHAIRMAN GREG
SHERIFF I GOT IN THE TO LINE
BUT TAKE THE UPPER TO ONCE
AGAIN. YOU NEED A GREATER
URAEUS CALL CALLED. YEAH SEAT
DAIS. THANK YOU. WELL NOT GO TO
LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE AHEAD.
I KNOW IN THE- AFTERNOON AS
SAYS TRAVEL CHAIR CENTER THE
RENTER. WE HAVE WORK TO OKAY
PEOPLE ALL ONE DOLLAR ONE OR
TWENTY NINE ABOUT WISHED OPPOSE
THIS SEASON. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR. YEAH I WANNA GO TO
LINE UP ONE FORTY SIX THE
AIRLINE OPEN. THIS IS THE LEVEL
WOULD THE CONGRESS OF RACIAL.
ONE OF AMERICA'S MOST VENERABLE
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATION I WAS
PUT INTO THE LONGVIEW. AND WE
ARE ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AC. I TRIED DOING NOTED THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. TO
LEARN I CALLED TIMELINE AND
TWENTY FIFTH YOU HAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE TWENTY SIX ZERO
LINE IS NOW OPEN YOU MAY BE
NEEDED. RIGHT WILL NOT GO TO
LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I AM FORTY ROMERO
CHAIRMAN OF THE BROADBAND
MISSION IT. ON BEHALF OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED NINE TROUBLED
MEMBERS. ACTUALLY OUR TRIBAL
ELDER. IN ORDER REAP STAFF
MEMBERS. WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. THE
ONE THAT CALLED TO LINE FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
AIRLINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THAT THIS IS CHRIS
RIGHT CHAIRMAN DRY CREEK
RANCHERIA SOMETHING ONLY COUNTY
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THE
ONE I GO TO LINE SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. LINE SIXTY
YOU MAY BE NEEDED. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBER THAT
PUTTING ABOUT RECALL DIRECTOR
OF TRIBAL DEVELOPMENT WITH THE
TWENTY NINE ALL SPENDING
MISSION INDIANS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU SIR. I WILL
NOT GO TO LINE A ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE
CATALINA CICCONE VICE CHAIR OF
THE TRIBAL ALLIANCE THE
SOVEREIGN INDIAN NATION A
COALITION OF TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
THE ROUTE THAT IN CALIFORNIA.
CAPTAIN IS STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
ADD THE EIGHT SIX WE CANNOT
HEAR THE BILL AS ANYTHING OTHER
THAN YET ANOTHER BETRAYAL OF AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AN INDIAN TRIBE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THE ONE I CALLEDTO
LINE AT ONE FIFTY THREE PEOPLE
HAD. ONE THREE AIRLINE AS
THOUGH. HELLO HELLO. WE CAN
AREA OKAY LOOKING AT THE ROBERT
UP FROM A YEAR TO DO YOU WANT
NATION AND- ON THE WALL WHO TRY.
AND LOCAL WILL BE WHICH
FOLLOWED AS. THANK YOU SIR.
WHEN I GO TO LINE IT WILL FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS CAN A CON
CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE BAND TO
MATCH INDIAN. ON BEHALF OF OUR
COMMUNITY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. ONE I
GO TO LINE A ONE OH FOUR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CARE MEMBERS MY
NAME'S SEAN PLAN AGAIN
REPRESENTING THE SCORN TRIBE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO FTA SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I KNOW
NOT TO GO TO LINE AT ONE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. YES ON BEHALF OF
THE COLUSA INDIAN COMMUNITY
WITH A HUNDRED NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTEEN FAMILY WE
EMPLOY ARE ARE ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED BEGIN THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL AND-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU AT THE MOMENT. MODERATOR
CAN YOU DO ME A FAVOR AND ASK
ONE FINAL TIME IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN SUPPORT. YEAH AND AS
A REMINDER TO UPHOLD THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN TO UPHOLD THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL CALL TIMELINE
AT ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR MIND IS OPEN. THE
GERMAN BOMBERS EDDIE MURRAY
PALM ON BEHALF OF OUR THREE
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
INTERSECTION- DRUG THE MEMBERS
WE STRONGLY HOLDERS THE BILL. I
DON'T WANT ANY MISUNDERSTANDING
ARE CURRENTLY FROM WORKING FOR
YEARS STARTING WITH. THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BROWN TURNING
GENERAL HERITAGE LOW THE
TURNING GENERAL. OF THE BUT
SERRA DO DRUG ENFORCEABLE LAW
THE LONG TERM FORCED ON US
BILLION PEOPLE WHY DON'T THE
SAME RULES APPLY THE CARD
ROOMS. FOR SO LONG WORKING
CALIFORNIA STATE CONSTITUTION
ALL YOU PEOPLE SITTING UP THERE
ORDER. HONOR TO BE LOOKING
RIGHT. THANK YOU WE SAW OPPOSE
OF THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I
WANNA GO TO LINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL I HAD YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. THE OTHER TRIED THAT
DOESN'T HAWKINS. IT'S ALL THE
MEMBERS ARE CRIED UP IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL TO
BEGIN. THANK YOU. AND THERE'S
NO ONE IN Q. AT THE MOMENT
LET'S GO LET'S ASK ONE FINAL
TIME AND THEN WE'LL PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR. AND AS A
REMINDER TO UPHOLD THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE ARE AT
THAT TIME. AGAIN TO UPHOLD THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ALL AT THIS TIME. HELLO
LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE Q.
AND UP IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
THIS. ALI WAY AGAIN TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL WIND AND ZERO. IT
WILL NOT GO TO LINE AT ONE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD TO
YOUR MIND OPEN. RIGHT EIGHT
ZIRIN AYE DADDY BAKULA THIS
VOTE AND WAS UNIONS
REPRESENTING FIFTEEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS AND OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THE- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. THEN WE HAVE
NO NO THANK YOU AT THE MOMENT.
THANK YOU MODERATOR. AND I WANT
TO THANK ALL THOSE THAT
TESTIFIED IN BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME WILL
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS SO AT THESE TIMES
APPROPRIATE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. SENATOR
GORGEOUS. THANK YOU. THIS IS
BEEN A BIT OF A LEARNING
EXPERIENCE FOR ME- I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO-
AND- SENATOR DODD AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY- FOR THE EXTENSIVE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE HAD- IN
THE LAST- TWENTY FOUR HOURS IN
PARTICULAR- RESULTS IS A
LEARNING EXPERIENCE FOR ME. I
AM IN MY SECOND YEAR IN SENATE
BUT EVEN THOUGH THIS ISSUE HAS
CERTAINLY BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES I HADN'T HAD OCCASION
TO FULLY APPRECIATE- THE
POSITIONS IN THE ARGUMENTS AND
THE FACTS AND HISTORY OF THIS
MATTER. BUT THINGS THAT I'VE
LOOKED ARE THAT. DRIVE IN CARD
ROOMS ARE CERTAINLY IN A
PROTRACTED BATTLE. I THINK THAT
IS THAT IS PRETTY PRETTY CLEAR
HERE. THAT THERE ARE TWO
LAWSUITS ARE UNDER WAY- THAT WE
HAVE NOT HEARD. OF THE OF THE
COURTS- RENDERING DECISIONS YET.
WHAT ALSO IS THAT WE'VE HAD
THREE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S- WHO
HAVE HAD JURISDICTION ON SOME
OF THESE ISSUES THAT HAVEN'T
PROVIDED ENOUGH CLARITY TO
RESOLVE SO THE MOST OUTSTANDING
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED NOW AS
AN ATTORNEY- I WOULD LIKE TO GO
TO LEARN AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE ON
THESE ISSUES AND I ALSO RELY
ON- FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE LITTLE
DEPARTMENTS TO PROVIDE. I WANT
THINGS THAT A LOT YEAR WAS POSE
A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS TO LEAD
COUNSEL. SPECIFICALLY TRY TO
UNDERSTAND. DOES THE
EXCLUSIVITY OF EXIST. DO CARD
ROOMS PRACTICE IN ENGAGING
GAMES THAT ARE IN VIOLATION OF
A CONTACT A NUMBER OF OTHERS.
WHAT I WAS SURPRISED IS THAT I
GOT ZERO RESPONSE FROM OUR
LEGAL ADVISERS IN THE WRIST IN
THE FACT THAT THERE WAS NO
RESPONSE IT WAS EXPLAINED. IT
WAS EXPLAINED AWAY. THAT
BECAUSE THIS MATTER WAS IN
LITIGATION THAT THEY WOULD NOT-
PINE OR PROVIDE INSIGHTS INTO
IT NOW FROM A LEGISLATOR
STANDPOINT I THINK THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE. THAT
IF WE ARE REALLY GOING ON
UNDERSTANDING AN ISSUE AND EVEN
IF ONE IS CURRENTLY IN THE
MIDST OF LITIGATION THAT WE
SHOULD NOT BE AFRAID TO GET
ANSWERS OF MARLEY BERMAN SO
THAT'S A PERSONAL GRIEVANCE ON
ON. THE OTHER ISSUE IS THIS IS
A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN POLICY.
ONE THAT I BELIEVE DESERVES A
LOT OF EXAMINATION IN A LOT OF
EXPLANATION AND A LOT OF- BOXES
GETTING CHECKED ON THE DUE
DILIGENCE THAT WOULD NORMALLY
BE EXPECTED IN A- ISSUE THIS. I
GOT THE BILL ANALYSIS YESTERDAY
EVENING. I'M STILL I'M
SCRATCHING MY HEAD HERE I'M
JUST I'M ADDING UP THE
CHALLENGES NO I UNDERSTAND THAT
COVERT IS CHANGED VIRTUALLY
EVERYTHING THE FACT THAT THERE
WERE. WEARING MASKS IN IN A
PORTION OF US ARE IN THIS ROOM-
AND WE ONLY HAVE ONE STAFFER IN
EACH OF OUR OFFICES EVERYTHING
BEING DONE REMOTELY AND
PROTESTERS FOR TWO NIGHTS IN A
ROW AND HAVE BEEN- MAKING SURE.
OF THAT. I UNDERSTAND. THINGS
WE'RE- BUT IT DOESN'T OBVIATE
THE NEED TO GET INFORMATION IN
A TIMELY FASHION SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE INFORMED- JUDGMENTS ON OR
AT LEAST ALLOW US TO GET FOLLOW
UP- EIGHT THREE SATISFIED. I
HAPPEN TO BE AN ALL IN. I
HAPPEN TO BE OF THE OPINION
THAT. NGUYEN REASONABLE ALL
COME TOGETHER EVEN IF THEY ARE
STAUNCHLY PROTECTING THEIR
JURISDICTION THEIR TERRITORY OR
THEIR REVENUE SOURCE. THAT
THERE IS A SOLUTION TO BE HAVE.
IT BAFFLES ME TO THINK THAT WE
CANNOT FIND A WAY FOR THESE
PARTIES TO COME TOGETHER
WHETHER IT BE IN A REVENUE
SHARING AGREEMENT FOR BETTER
MORE LIKE FULL UNDERSTANDING OF
WHERE THE PARTIES CAN OPERATE
FREELY. I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT HAPPEN. NOW WHAT I'VE BEEN
TOLD BY CERTAIN FOLKS IN THIS
GOES BACK TO THE HE SAID SHE
SAID EXPERIENCE THAT I'VE EXT-
THAT I'VE HAD ON THIS ISSUE IT
THAT. NO THIS CONTACTED- SOME
OF THESE PEOPLE AND THEY'VE
NEVER HAD A SEAT AT THE TABLE
SOME PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT'S
THE- AND OTHERS ARE STAYING
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY PATENTLY
FALSE. WHO DO I BELIEVE I MEAN
THIS IS LITERALLY THE IT IS
SHOWERED IN A GRAY ZONE OF
MISINFORMATION FALSE NARRATIVES
AND FALSE CHOICES FOR THAT
MATTER. I BELIEVE THE PARTIES
NEED TO COME TO THE TABLE TO
RESOLVE THIS ISSUE. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT GIVEN CODE
WITHIN THE PROTESTS IN THE
TIMELINE OF BRINGING A BALLOT
ISSUE FOR TO FORWARD HAS LEFT
US WITH LITTLE ROOM TO
NEGOTIATE AND MANEUVER. EVEN IF
AS SOME PEOPLE HAVE SUGGESTED
APPROVE IT SO WE CAN BEGIN
NEGOTIATING THAT'S NOT REALLY
MY STYLE AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE AND
THE SOPHISTICATION THE BODY OF
THE ISSUE. BUT SHOULD THIS
BEFORE TO STAY IN SPEC INSPECT
IT WILL. ONE ONE OR TWO THINGS
THAT CAN MAKE THIS BETTER. IS
THAT WE REFINE THE FARM THAT
THE FUNDING FOR BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW IT'S GOING TO GO INTO A
GENERAL FUND A WELFARE FUND- TO
BE GONE AFTER BY A VARIETY OF
FOLKS AS THE SEARCH COMING IN.
I THINK WE'LL BE BETTER SERVED
IF WE FORCE AND ARTICULATION OF
WHAT OR THE OR THE RECIPIENT
AREAS OF CALIFORNIA. CATION
HIGHER IN PRIMARY HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I BELIEVE THAT IT
WOULD BE BETTER AND MORE
BENEFICIAL TO CALIFORNIANS IF
WE KNEW WHERE THIS FUN MONEY
WAS GOING TO GO AND LET'S NOT
KID OURSELVES WE TALK ABOUT
KOBE NINETEEN- YOU KNOW IT
SHOWING US THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE IN IN THE RED FOR A
SIGNIFICANT TIME AHEAD. THE
ESTIMATIONS OF FOR HUNDRED
MILLION. IS THE FACT THAT WERE
FIFTY FOUR BILLION IN THE RED
SO CAN THIS BE HELPFUL YES.
WILL THIS CHANGE OUR ECONOMIC
OUTLOOK. PROBABLY NOT THIS IS
ONE OF MANY SERIOUS DISCUSSIONS
A WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE
AS A BODY ON WHAT OUR NEEDS ARE
VERSES ARE WANTS WHAT OUR
PRIORITIES AS CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS- IT. ALSO WE MOVE
FORWARD AS A STATE ALL. MY
CONCERN IS THAT IS THIS MOVES
FORWARD WE TALKED ABOUT MAKING
THIS ACTIVATED IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY WITH ALL THE
REGULATIONS- THAT WOULD GO
ALONG BEHIND IT PROBABLY
LOOKING AT ANOTHER YEAR THERE
AFTER. MY CONCERN IS THAT THE
TRIBES ARE GOING TO TAKE THIS
TO COURT IN THIS WILL BE STUCK
IN LITIGATION FOR SIGNIFICANT
PERIOD OF TIME. SO ONE OF
COMBINATIONS THAT I WOULD HAVE
IS THAT IF THIS DOESN'T PASS
FORWARD TODAY OR DOES IT PASSED
THE SENATE WERE THE ENTIRE
PROCESS. THAT WE IMMEDIATELY
READMISSION EIGHT. A FULL IN
COMPREHENSIVE DISCUSSION WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS SO NO ONE CAN
EVER SAY THAT THEY WEREN'T AT
THE TABLE. ALSO THIS IDEA THAT
THAT THE ONLINE GAMING. IS NOT
GOING TO COME TO CALIFORNIA I
THINK. I THINK IT WILL BE
COMING TO CALIFORNIA WHETHER
IT'S TODAY OR OR A YEAR FROM
NOW. IT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
BECAUSE IT IS VIRTUALLY
INEVITABLE. NOW HOW WE GO ABOUT
CREATING A REVENUE SHARING
AGREEMENT THAT LOOKS AFTER THE
INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS THE EXISTING STAKEHOLDERS-
SOME OF WHICH HAD MAYBE
INVESTED IN MAJOR CAPITAL
EXPANSION INFRASTRUCTURES. WITH
THE EXPECTATION OF REVENUES
BEING ON A MORE EXCLUSIVE BASIS.
WITH THAT BEING SAID I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR FROM ANY ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT HAS MORE
EXPERIENCE IN DEALING WITH
TRIBES IN CARD ROOMS IN PONIES-
I MYSELF REPRESENTING ALL OR
PARTS OF ELEVEN COUNTIES HAVE
HEARD FROM FOLKS IN THE PONIES-
CARD ROOMS- FROM THE FAIR
BOARDS AND FROM THE TRIBES AND
I PRESENTED. THEM BUT I. ONLY
IF THERE IS A PATH FORWARD.
ENTER IN PRESUME LOSERS- WITH
THE WAY IT EXISTS RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
PORCHES. OR ANY OTHER MY EX
RAISED. SIR WIENER. THANK YOU
SERVICE I WANT TO THANK
CHAIRMAN DOG FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
IN GERMAN GRAY AS WELL- THESE
ARE LONG FESTERING IN USE AND-
TAKES LEADERSHIP AND BEING-
WILLING TO HAVE THE SLINGS AND
ARROWS COME OUT HERE TO TAKE ON
AND TRY TO. ATTEMPT TO BROKER
RESOLUTION ON SOME HARD IS. AND
THIS ONE- IT ADDRESSES TO I I'M
NOT AN EXPERT ON GAMBLING BUT I
KNOW ENOUGH. TO KNOW THAT THE
TRIED CARD ROOM BRAWL- AND THE
ISSUE WITH SPORTS BETTING
DISTURBANCES FLOATING AROUND
FOR AWHILE AND ARE NOT BEING
ADDRESSED THIS IS A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT TO ADDRESS SOME. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY- I WON A
SECOND ON COLLEAGUES SAY MAN
AND I KNOW THE AUTHORS ARE
COMMITTED TO THIS TO BRING THE
PART TO BE ABLE. NOTHING THOSE
ARE FEW GREATER IN CENTER TO
COME THE- AFTER COMES OF
COMMITTEE. IT BECOMES VERY REAL
AT THAT POINT AND I'M CONFIDENT
THE AUTHORS PARTY CHAIRMAN
WILL. WILL BRING THE TRIBES
CARTONS EVERYONE ELSE THE
TABLE. TO TRY TO WORK THROUGH
THIS OF COURSE WE NEED TO TWO
THIRDS VOTE. ON THE FLOOR- I
KNOW FROM FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE
IT'S HARD. BUT I HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THESE AUTHORS SO
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
SENATOR GALGIANI. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR- I
HAVE CONCERNS OF WANTING TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND THE
FINANCIAL WELL BEING OF OUR
TRIBAL CASINOS THEIR BRICK AND
MORTAR FACILITIES AND IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT WE HAVE
ABOUT NINE BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF WAGES THAT BIT PLATE
HAVE BEEN PAID TO EMPLOYEES AND
ONE. AND NOT. I TO VIEW AND
ADDRESS TO THE STATE TO EMPLOY
SUCH A LARGE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS AND CREATE JOBS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS I WANT TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH OF THAT- MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS I JUST WOULD
LIKE YOU TO VERIFY FOR ME WITH
TO THE ONLINE WAGERING AND THE
ROLE OF THE TRIBES. I
UNDERSTAND TO THIS BILL THAT
THE SPORTS BETTING WOULD BE
ALLOWED ON SITE. AND ONLINE BY
THE TRIBES AND ALSO. WITH HORSE
RACING. AND CAN YOU JUST
CLARIFY FOR US AND THE PEOPLE
BETWEEN THE TRIBES AND THEIR
ONLINE AND THEY'RE ON SITE
WAGERING AND THE HOW THAT
LICENSING ARRANGEMENT WILL WORK.
THE THANK YOU SENATOR- THROUGH
THE CHAIR- YOU'VE GOT A RIGHT
THEY WILL HAVE THE ABILITY DO
ONLINE AND THEY'LL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO- OBVIOUSLY DO BRICKS
AND MORTARS IN FACT BECAUSE
FURTHER IN THE IN THE TRIBAL
INITIATIVE WHICH- YOU ONLY BUT
FOR THE- CLOVER NINETEEN
SITUATION WHAT A QUALIFIED IN
THE OF MY ESTIMATION. THE OVER
THE NUMBER OF SIGNATURES- IN
THERE ARE- INITIATIVE- THEY-
YOUR GAVE THE RIGHTS TO HORSE
RACING AND THEMSELVES FOR
SPORTS BETTING AT BRICKS AND
MORTAR WHAT WE DO IN OURS IS.
SINCE SINCE ALL THE LINE IS 80%
OF THE TOTAL BETTING MAYBE EVEN
AS MUCH AS 85% WE HAVE TO
INCLUDE. YOUR LIFE SO WE GAVE
THE SAME BETTER THE FOR THE
SAME TO THE TRIBES IN THE HORSE
RACING WITH THE FOR THE TRIBES
TO BE ABLE TO. LICENSE OTHER
INTO THESE OUT AT. I BELIEVE
THEIR DISCRETION CHAIRMAN DO
YOU HAVE. I'LL JUST ADD TO THAT
THAT. THAT'S ACCURATE 85290% OF
SPORTS WAGERING REVENUE IN THE
TWENTY TWO OTHER STATES TO DO
THIS IS DERIVED FROM ONLINE.
WHICH WAY DURING TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD HAVE THE
OPTION YOU BOTH HAVE A BRICK
AND MORTAR SPORTS BOOK- MUCH
LIKE YOU MAY HAVE SEEN IF
YOU'VE EVER TRAVELED TO CASINO
IN LAS VEGAS- NEW JERSEY ROUSE
WHERE AS WELL AS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER THAT
PRODUCT. ONLINE AS WELL SO
HORSE RACING- LICENSE FOR
TRICKS IT WOULD ALSO HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER THAT
ONLINE AND I MIGHT ADD IN A IN
RESPONSE OF THE COMMENTS THAT.
IF ANYONE'S GOING TO SUGGEST.
THIS IS A BRAND NEW TOPIC. THAT
THEY JUST READ ABOUT LAST
NIGHT. THEY'VE EITHER BEEN
ASLEEP. OR NOT DOING THEIR JOB
HERE AT THE LEGISLATURE WE HAD
A MULTI HOUR. JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
TOP TWO SPORTS WAGER WITH TONS
OF LEGAL ANALYSIS FROM- FROM
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS FROM CARD
CLUBS AND OTHER. STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE INDUSTRY WE'VE SPENT
HUNDREDS OF HOURS LITERALLY
MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
ACROSS THE BOARD WE'VE DONE
THAT OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST FOUR YEARS READ A TOUGH
POINT. IN THE ROAD RIGHT NOW
WITH- FOLKS HAVING OPPOSING
IDEAS AND POSITIONS AND
HOPEFULLY AND I THINK SOME OF
THE CENTERS FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
WE WILL BE ABLE TO FIND THAT
COMPROMISE BUT DOES THAT ANSWER
QUESTIONS. YES IT DOES THANK
YOU AND MY SECOND QUESTION IS
RELATED TO HORSE RACING AND THE
FAIRS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WE ALL KNOW OUR
AFFAIRS HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING
FOR SOME TIME AND PARTICULARLY
WITH THE CROWN OF VIRUS
EPIDEMIC THAT WE'RE ALL AND
NOW. SO MY QUESTION IS EVEN
THOUGH IT'S VERY SPECIFIC IN
THE ANALYSIS THAT THE SPORT
WHICH ALLOWED REYES TRY ALAMY
M. MáS ANGELES ORANGE OR SAN
DIEGO COUNTIES. WELL IT CAN
TAKE DISCUSSIONS. WHAT A HORSE
USING INDUSTRY AND THE- TO
ENSURE THAT THERE COULD BE A
FOR SO BENEFIT THE FAIRS THAT
ARE NOT SPECIFICALLY LISTED
HERE. AS AS THE CHAIRMAN-
GRAVES IS SAID WERE WILLING TO
HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS WITH
EVERYBODY I MIGHT POINT OUT.
THAT FOR EVERY NEW LICENSE SEE
THAT YOU HAVE. YOU ALSO HAVE
THE PERHAPS OPPOSITION- FROM
THE TO FROM THE TRIBE SO WE
WANT TO BE VERY VERY CAREFUL
THAT WE DON'T CONTINUE TO ADD
OFTEN A CAUSE FURTHER ACHES SO
IT'S GOING TO BE A DELICATE-
DANCE. BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
IDEAS OF HOW THAT POSSIBLY
COULD WORK WE TALKED TO SOME OF
THE FAIR REPRESENTATIVES I AM
VERY REASONABLE AND EVERY
CLASS. THIS DOWN IT SAYS IT
WILL BE DOING LIKE YEAH. FROM
MY TO THAT I KNOW YOU'RE FROM
WITH THE LEGISLATION THAT I
WORKED FOR SEVERAL YEARS RIGHT
HERE AB FOURTEEN NINETY NINE
YES I AM WHICH- TAKES A PORTION
OF THE SALES TAX REVENUE SPENT
AT FAIR GROUNDS AND GIVES IT
BACK TO FAIR GROUNDS- FARES ARE
NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART. AS
YOU KNOW A GIRL. CULTURAL
COMMUNITY. I THINK I AM WELL I
KNOW I AM VERY CONCERNED. COM
WE NEED TO RE ALIGN THE STATE'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH FAIRS GOING
FORWARD- AS A PART OF OUR
BUDGET CUTS COMING UP HERE
MEMBERS AND I THINK PART OF
THIS DISCUSSION AROUND THIS
ISSUE WHETHER IT'S CERTAIN FAIR
FACILITIES HAVING BASINS SPORTS
WAITER SODAS OR WHETHER IT'S
SHIP FAIRS SHARING IN SOME
REVENUE. DERIVED FROM THE
ACTIVITY AT A LIKE IF YOU WERE-
BACK IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES
LEOPARD OR TWO THOUSAND WHEN WE
HAD- THE FAIR SHARE THE HORSE
RACING REVENUE- AT ONE TIME AND
THEN THAT WAS TAKEN OUT THE BAD
BUDGET YEAR. RECESSION THERE IS
THAT WHAT. HERE'S ONE WE'VE NOW
SOME FIVE AND DO THE CO CRIES
THE GOVERNOR'S LOOKING AND
REALIZING THAT RELATIONSHIPS SO
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT TO BRING
UP THE ISSUE I THINK THIS IS A
KEY AVENUE THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THAT SOMEONE RESPECT DOT COM
WHICH IS YOU KNOW EVERY THIS IS
ALL GIVEN TECH AND EVERYONE
THAT. A LOT. TAKE FROM SOME
ELSE AND THAT'S WE FOR THE
TABLE AND YOUR DECISION TO MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD TODAY. GIVES
US AN OPPORTUNITY. SURE THAT
EVEN THOSE THAT HAVE WALKED
AWAY FROM THE TABLE CAN COME
BACK. THANK YOU. CENTER BRAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANT TO THANK BOTH AUTHOR
SENATOR DODD AND CHAIRMAN- GRAY
FOR THIS MEASURE AS I HAVE
LISTENED- THIS IS NOT A NEW
ISSUE FOR THE LEGISLATURE- AND
BY. WE NOW HAVE NINE YEARS OF
BEING HERE THIS IS A ISSUE THAT
HAS BEEN A WIDELY DISCUSSED AND
DEBATED MY PREDECESSOR SENATOR
ROD RIGHT EVEN MADE A VALIANT
EFFORT AT. MOVING THIS ISSUE
FORWARD IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
MADE TO ISSUE THAT. AFTER STUDY
LONG AYE AYE SIGNAL LOSERS
HERE. I SEE WINNERS. WINNERS ON
BOTH SIDES. FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE'RE ALLOWING IF THERE'S LIKE
AN EXPANSION OF GAMING. THAT
EXPANSION IS BEING AFFORDED OUR
NATIVE AMERICAN BROTHERS AND
SISTERS. CENTER BRADFORD HI CAN
I ASK YOU TO PUT PUT ON YOUR
MASK AND ALL OTHER MEMBERS TO
PUT THEIR MASS ON I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT YOU CARRYING ON
BUSINESS AND I WAS IS THAT YOUR
GET YOUR GET YOUR GOING TO GET
ON A ROLL YEAH THIS IS NOT
IDEAL I KNOW SPACE I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE APPRECIATE IT. BUT AGAIN IF
THERE IS AN EXPANSION OF GAMING
I THINK THAT EXPANSION HAS BEEN
AFFORDED TO. OUR NATIVE
AMERICAN BROTHERS AND SISTERS
BY FORTY NAY ON THAT ADD
ADDITIONAL NEW GAMES AS WELL AS
SPORTS WAGERING WHAT IS CARD
ROOMS GET GAME AND THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING. THEY'RE
BEING AFFORDED TO PLAY A GAME
THAT THEY'VE BEEN PLAYING FOR
TWENTY YEARS. NOTHING NEW
THEY'RE NOT EXPANDING ANYTHING
THAT THEY HAVE HAVING ALREADY
BEEN DOING. AND AS AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO GREW UP IN THE
CITY OF GARDENA AS A CHILD WE
HAD SIX CARD ROOMS WHEN HOUSING
AT A GROWN UP IN GUARDIAN. WE
PAID FULL SUPPORT NO TO ROBERT
TAX. AND ADDITIONAL OTHER.
OPERA AT THE CAR ROOMS PROVIDED
OUTSIDE OF- TAX REVENUE FOR THE
CITY AND- MAJOR EMPLOYMENT AS
WELL TODAY GUARDINO HAS TWO
CLUBS. TO AND- IT'S DUE TO THE
EXPANSION OF NOT ONLY LAS VEGAS
AS WELL AS OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WE ARE NOW
DOWN TO TWO. BUT WE HAVE FOUND
A WAY TO SURVIVE I HAVE FOR
COURT ROOMS IN MY DISTRICT. ONE
IN THE CITY OF INGLEWOOD. AND
ONE IN THE CITY OF CARSON. AND
FOR ALL OF US WHO HAVE GONE THE
LAS VEGAS I'M PRETTY SURE
YOU'VE ALL HEARD OF PRIMA
DONNA. WELL BERNIE BROWN AGE
PRIMA DONNA. HE STARTED IN
GARDENA. THE GUARD THE CAR.
SIXTIES EARLY SEVENTIES HE LEFT
TO THE CONVENTION OPPORTUNITIES
AND LAS VEGAS HE SET HIS
OPERATION RIGHT THERE ON THE
BORDER OF A CALIFORNIA NEVADA
SO. AGAIN CAR ROOMS IF ANYONE
HAS SUFFERED ITS I MEAN IF
ANYONE HAS SUFFERED OVER THE
LAST TWENTY THIRTY YEARS IT'S
THE CARD ROOMS AND WE'VE HAD.
MEMBERS ATTORNEY GENERAL'S WHO
HAVE LOOKED AT THIS ISSUE AND
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO
STATED THE REASON THEY HAVE NOT
RULED. ON IT IS BECAUSE IT'S A
GRAY AREA DRESS BUT- PROP ONE
EIGHTY DID NOT GIVE NATIVE
AMERICANS EXCLUSIVITY. WHEN IT
CAME TO CAR A GALE MEXICAN
SEVENTY. WHEN IT CAME THE SLOT
MACHINES AND THERE'S NOT A
SINGLE CARD ROOM IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHO WOULDN'T WANT
A SLOT MACHINE IN THEIR
FACILITY BUT NOT A SINGLE ONE
IS LOOKING FOR THAT. NOT A
SINGLE ONE IS ASKING FOR THAT
ALL THEY'RE ASKING TO DO IS A
FORTY ON THE OPPORTUNITY. THE
CAN CONTINUE TO PLAY A GAME
THAT THEY HAVE PLAYED. WHAT
OUT. MUCH PROBLEMS OF THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS WITHOUT MUCH.
LEGAL ACTIVITY YOU HAVE ME DO
WE CAN POINT TO LEGAL ACTIVITY
IN ALMOST ANYTHING THAT WE DO
FROM. LEGALIZE SPORTS TO
WHATEVER THERE'S- AZ MRS GOALS
ON BUT- I KNOW AGAIN I HAD SIX
CAR ROOMS IN MY CITY I HAVE TO
NOW NOT ONLY HAD ANY PROBLEMS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND
CONTINENT INGLEWOOD NOT. ISSUES
TWENTY LEGAL GAMES PEOPLE BEING
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF. AND I SEE
HERE IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
ALLOW OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS TO EXPAND
THAT WHICH THEY ARE DOING
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
QUITE WELL OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS AGAIN AS A MEMBER
GUARDINO CITY COUNCIL TWENTY
YEARS AGO WHEN THIS ISSUE WAS
ON THE BALLOT I STOOD OUT AS
THE LONE MEMBERS CITY COUNCIL
AND SUPPORTING THE RIGHTS FOR
IT NATIVE AMERICAN COMPACTS I
STILL WITH THE MAN. DESPITE THE
PERSONS THAT I GOT FROM MY CAR
OWNERS ARE MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
COUNCIL AND I STAND WITH- NOW
BUT I ASKED US TO STAND IN
UNITY SPACE IN LIGHT OF COLD
IT. THE LIGHT OF THE RACISM
THAT IS HAPPENING IN THIS STATE
AND IN ITS MASON THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE ALVY
SUBORDINATE TODAY. MISTER
BRADFORD. CENTER GLAZER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
I CERTAINLY JOIN IN- THE PRAISE
OF THE AUTHORS OF THIS MEASURE
A SENATOR GUIDED SELLING MEMBER
GRAY I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
WORKING WITH SENATOR DOT FOR
MANY YEARS HE'S A MAN OF GREAT
INTEGRITY LEADERSHIP AND TO
TAKE ON AN ISSUE LIKE THIS
SPEAKS TO- THE EXPERTISE THAT
HE HAS GAINED THE COURAGE THAT
HE AND FOUR TO TWO THIRTY HAS
WE KNOW HOW HARD AN ISSUE LIKE
THIS IS AND IS DESERVING OF
GREAT. PRAISE FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP. I HAVE HAD A VERY
SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP- WITH THE
INDIAN COMMUNITY GOING BACK
TWENTY TWO YEARS. AND THAT
RELATIONSHIP HAS ALLOWED ME TO
GET TO KNOW AND UNDERSTAND. A
LEADERSHIP IT'S THERE TODAY BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE HISTORY
THE HISTORY OF THE INDIANS.
HERE IN OUR STATE. AND IT'S AN
UGLY HISTORY. NOW I KNOW THAT'S
NOT THE PURPOSE OF THE ISSUE
BEFORE US TODAY BUT IT'S WORTH
AT EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT
UPON. THAT HISTORY AND IT COMES
AT A TIME WHERE WE HAVE OUR OWN
PANDEMIC BUT FOR THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY DISEASE
BROUGHT IN FROM THE OUTSIDE WAS
IS CERTAINLY A KILLER OF.
THOUSANDS THEY HAD WARS THEY
HAD MASSACRES MASSACRES BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. LED BY
LEADERS OF OUR STATE. PUT OUT
BOUNTIES. BUT THE SCALLOPS OF
INDIANS PART OF OUR UGLY
HISTORY AS A STATE. AND THEN OF
COURSE THEY WERE PUT ON
RESERVATIONS. AND THEN NOT TOO
FAR AFTER THAT THEY WERE KICKED
OFF RESERVATIONS. AND FINALLY
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE LAST
CENTURY. THEY WERE TOLD TO
REESTABLISH RESERVATIONS TO
JUSTIFY RESERVATIONS AND WHERE
DID THEY PUT THEM. THEY PUT
THEM IN THE UNDESIRABLE PARTS
OF OUR STATE. NEXT THE GARBAGE
STOPS. FAR AWAY FROM CITIES ON
LAND THAT WAS SO DESOLATE HE
COULDN'T EVEN GROW CROPS THAT'S
WHAT WE DID. THAT'S WHAT OUR
GOVERNMENT DID. AND ALL THE
RECEIPT WAS PALTRY HELP. FROM
OUR FEDERAL LEADERS ANIMALS
NOTHING FROM THE STATE AND SO
WHAT HAPPENED. DOOR INDIAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. MASSIVE
POVERTY. MASSIVE UNEMPLOYMENT.
NOW IN THE. END OF THE LAST
CENTURY. NAY START ENTERPRISES
ON THEIR LAND. GAMING
ENTERPRISES OF COURSE WHAT
HAPPENED. FEDERAL RAIDS FEDERAL
PROSECUTION ACCUSATIONS THAT
THEY WERE ACTING ILLEGALLY.
TRYING TO MAKE A LIVING ON
THEIR LAND AND THEY FACED
ANOTHER. PERSECUTE FORM OF
PERSECUTION. ATTACK THAT THEIR
GAMES WERE LEGAL UNDER THE
STATE CONSTITUTION. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. TO WORK WITH THEM
INTIMATELY ON THIS PROBLEM. AND
WAS PLEASED TO JOIN WITH THEM
IN PUTTING FORTH TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA PROPOSITION FIVE
TO LEGALIZE THOSE GAMES.
BECAUSE OF THE LEGAL CHALLENGES
AFTER THE PASSAGE THAT MEASURE.
THEY HAD TO COME BACK TWO YEARS
LATER FOR PROPOSITION ONE A THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA SETTLED
THIS DISPUTE FIND GAINES. WE
THOUGHT. AND THAT SETTLEMENT
ALLOWED THE TRIBES. TO BEGIN TO
CREATE PROSPERITY FOR THEIR
MEMBERS. NOT FOR ALL TRIBES FOR
MANY TRIBES IN THE STATE OVER A
HUNDRED MANY OF THEM DON'T EVEN
HAVE THAT THE ADVANTAGES OF
GAMING TO IMPROVE THEIR
SITUATION. SO I HAVE THE
SPECIAL APPRECIATION FOR THIS
HISTORY AND I KNOW IT'S NOT
BEFORE US BUT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
THAT IT BE SAID ON THIS FLOOR.
THERE ARE TWO KEY ISSUES WHEN I
LOOK AT LEGISLATION THAT WE'RE
FACING TODAY. THAT ARE MOST
IMPORTANT TO ME. NUMBER ONE IT
PROTECTS THE SOVEREIGNTY OF THE
TRIBES THEIR TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
AS AT THE SAME AS CALIFORNIA
THEY DESERVE TO BE DEALT WITH
RESERVE WITH RESPECT. AND
NOTHING THAT WE SHOULD DO
SHOULD UNDERCUT. THAT ISSUE OF
SOVEREIGNTY. AND THE SECOND
STANDARD THAT I USE IN
EVALUATING BILLS LIKE THIS
TODAY IF THEIR ECONOMIC
SECURITY. WHAT PROP FIVE IN
PROP ONE EIGHT DID WAS GIVE
MANY OF THEM NOT ALL SOME LEVEL
OF ECONOMIC SECURITY BY
CREATING A FRANCHISE OF GAMING.
BUT COULDN'T BE REPLICATED IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE SO
THEY COULD PROSPER. AND THEY
HAVE PROSPERED. AND SO WHEN I
LOOK AT LEGISLATION. THAT WE
HAVE TODAY THOSE TWO OR THAT
THE TWO STANDARDS THAT I
EXAMINE CAREFULLY. AND WHEN I
LOOK AT THIS BILL. I DON'T
THINK IT PROTECTS THE FRANCHISE
OF THE TRIBE. I THINK THAT IT
ALLOWS FOR AN EXPANSION THAT
CAN POTENTIALLY ROAD THE
ECONOMIC SECURITY. OF THE
TRIBES. AND THAT TROUBLES ME
GREATLY. NOW IT DOES NOT MEAN
THAT I DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
CARD ROOMS OR THE RACE TRACKS I
HAVE CARD ROOMS IN MY DISTRICT
I HAVE A RACETRACK IN MY
DISTRICT. I AM SENSITIVE TO THE
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THOSE
ENTERPRISES HAVE IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. I AM SENSITIVE TO
THE JOBS THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED
GOOD JOBS. AND WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. BUT WHEN I LOOK AT
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
BEFORE US. IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
IT DOES NOT PROTECT THE
ECONOMIC SECURITY OF THE TRIBES.
THE INTERNET THE EXPANSION OF
GAMING ON THE INTERNET THROUGH
SPORTS BETTING HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO A ROAD THAT
FRANCHISE. AND IT- AS I SAID
TROUBLES ME I DO BELIEVE I
THINK THE SENATOR FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SAID IT'S
EARLIER I DO BELIEVE THERE CAN
BE A COMPROMISE HERE. THAT
PROVIDES FOR SECURITY. THE CARD
CLUBS IN THE RACETRACKS BUT
DOES IN A ROW THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY. OF THE TRIBES AND
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
AND I CERTAINLY. SHARE THE
SENTIMENTS THAT FULL
CONSULTATION. IS A REQUIREMENT.
SO FOR ME THIS BILL DOESN'T
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE I
STILL RESPECT THE AUTHOR I
EXPECT RESPECT HIS LEADERSHIP I
THINK HE CAN GET US TO A BETTER
PLACE BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
BILL BEFORE US. IS NOT THAT
PLACE. THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER.
I SEE NO OTHER MIKE'S UP SO.
CALL CENTER ARCHULETA I'M SORRY.
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER. I CONCUR WITH SENATOR
BRADFORD I THINK YOUR
PRESENTATION WAS OUTSTANDING
GOING BACK TO YOUR YOUTH SEE IN
SOMETHING. AS PROSPEROUS FOR
THE COMMUNITY SHRINK DOWN THE
TWO CASINOS IN OUR JUST THIRTY
SECONDS SENATE DISTRICT WE HAVE
THE CITY OF COMMERCE AND THEY
HAVE THE CASINO THERE AND
HAWAIIAN GARDENS THERE BECAUSE
THEIR CASINO THERE AND- JUST
ACROSS THE ROAD FROM MY THIRTY
SECOND SENATE-DISTRICT. WE HAVE
THE BICYCLE CLUB. THOUSANDS
UPON THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN
THOSE THREE CASINOS PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES IT IS VITAL THAT
THEY CONTINUE TO DO BUSINESS.
NOW BECAUSE THE CORONA VIRUS
THEIR SHUT DOWN I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT THE
COMMERCE CASINO JUST A FEW DAYS
AGO. AND OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO WHATEVER THEY CAN.
TO CREATE A SEPARATE
OPPORTUNITY SOME WAY SOMEHOW TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO WORK AND
EVERYTHING ELSE BUT IT'S JUST
NOT GONNA HAPPEN. JUST NOW SO
THEY'RE ALL GOING TO HAVE TO
INTO WE OPEN THE DOORS FOR
EVERYONE. THAT WE KNOW. BUT
THIS BILL AND I THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD. THAT THE TIME AND
EFFORT TO DO AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PUT TOGETHER. TO FIND AT THAT
EQUAL I GUESS WE'LL CALL THIS
THE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL.
THE TRIBESMEN I'VE BEEN TO THE
TO THE TRIBES I'VE SEEN WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES THERE SO I SEE THIS
BILL IS A MUCH AS A COMPROMISE
WERE GOING TO SEE. BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT THE MULTITUDE OF
YEARS THAT SOME OF YOU HAVE
BEEN IN THE SENATE YOU'VE SEEN
THE FIGHT. BUT NOW THE FIGHT IS
OVER I THINK IT'S TIME TO
UNITE. WITH WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE BILL. HOW THE CARD CLUBS
ARE JUST GOING TO HANG IN THERE
AND THAT'S ALL THEY'RE DOING
IS. THEY'RE NOT GETTING
ANYTHING THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS BILL. WITH ADDING TO THEIR
REVENUE IT IS NOTHING THIS
ADDING TO THEIR TOLD ME TO
THEIR OPERA. IT BE ABLE.
EVERYTHING IN. IS GO TO HELP HI
JIM THIS IS WHAT I'M SO EXCITED
ABOUT. BECAUSE NOW WE CAN SEE
THAT SOMEONE COULD CONTINUE TO
WORK AND SOMEONE IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO EXPAND THEIR HORIZONS.
AND BUILD THEIR COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY SO DESPERATELY NEED-
AROUND THE THAT THE AREAS OF
THE TRIBES. SO I I'M I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT IT I THANK YOU
SENATORDODD AND- ADAM GRAY FOR
WHAT YOU'VE DONE AND EVERYONE
HERE. THINK ABOUT WHAT THIS IS
IT THIS IS HISTORY AND WE'RE SO
PROUD I'M SO PROUD THAT WE'RE
FACING THIS THE BEST WAY TO
KEEP GOING IS THE PAST. THE
BILL AND I THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER ARCHULETA CENTER ALLEN
YOU SURE. OKAY GREAT THING.
CENTER PORTANTINO THANK YOU ARE
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
THAT'S HAPPENED TODAY- I AM
GOING TO SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATION TODAY AND ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO CONTINUE TALKING
BECAUSE I THINK WHEN WE TALK TO
EACH OTHER WE MAKE BETTER
PUBLIC POLICY AND OBVIOUSLY THE
NEXT STOP FOR THE BILL WILL BE
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AND I WELCOME THE CONTINUED
COOPERATION OF THE TWO CHAIRS
AND ALL OF THE PARTICIPANTS IF
IT GETS OFF THE FLOOR TODAY SO
I LOOK FOR THAT CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN PORTANTINO.
SEEING NO OTHER MIKE SET UP
CENTER GOD WOULD YOU CARE TO
CLOSE I YES I WOULD FIRST I'D
LIKE TO- SPEAK TO SENATOR
GLAZERS COMMENTS FIRST OF ALL I
AGREE WITH THE TWO STANDARDS
THAT YOU SET FOR. I THINK THOSE
ARE VERY VERY THOUGHTFUL AND I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY THAT GOES
UP ON THIS BILL TODAY. WOULD
DISAGREE WITH YOUR ASSESSMENT
THAT THOSE TWO STANDARDS ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO MOVING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND YOU'VE
GOT MY COMMITMENT. TO WORK WITH
YOU- ILL ON THAT IF THIS BILL-
GETS OUT TODAY- AS I SAID IN MY
OPENING COMMITMENT TO THE
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS TO IS TO NOT
MOVE THIS BILL. ON THE FLOOR
UNTIL WE'VE HAD THOSE
SUBSTANTIVE. GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS. AIMS RESOLVE YOUR
COMMENTS- SENATOR I WILL COMMIT
TO INCLUDING YOU IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND I WILL NOT
BRING THIS BILL ON THE FLOOR
UNTIL YOU FEEL THE CONCERNS.
HAVE BEEN ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED.
I ALSO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU. ALL THE
PEOPLE OF THE COMMENTED ON BOTH
SIDES PRO AND CON ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. BEFORE YOU
KNOW JUST FOR BEING HERE
PARTICIPATING SYSTEM BELIEVE ME
WHEN WE HEAR THE COMMENTS FOR
WE LEARN A LITTLE BIT. HERE THE
COMING TOGETHER YEAH I GUESS WE
LEARN OKAY A LITTLE BIT MORE.
AND CERTAINLY IN THIS PROCESS-
I'VE LEARNED A LOT AND I REALLY
DO BELIEVE THAT THERE'S LOTS OF
ROOM FOR MOVEMENT. A TO BRING
THE PARTIES TOGETHER. THERE ARE
SOME MANY ISSUES THAT STILL
NEED TO BE WORKED OUT WE'VE
HEARD THIS SONG ON THE FLOOR I
BELIEVE THAT- THIS SCA
REPRESENTS A COMPROMISE. FOR
THE GAMING INDUSTRY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
MODIFICATIONS AND TAKING AND
THOSE STANDARDS INTO ACCOUNT.
IS IT OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN DID
ALSO TO GERMAN GREAT YOU'RE THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE YOU CAN
DO WHAT YOU LIKE. THANK YOU-
SENATORS FOR THE DIALOGUE AND
THE ENGAGE DEBATE. ALL CONCUR
WITH MY- SENATE COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS. WE'RE BETTER OFF
HAVING HAD THIS DISCUSSION. I
PARTICULARLY WANT TO POINT OUT
CENTER GLAZER. BOTH STANDARDS.
AND ANSWERS THAT YOU REGISTER
AND I THINK RAY SO TRIM
IMPORTANT CONCEPTS. THE FULL
CONSULTATION RESPECT. SOVEREIGN
GOVERNMENTS. AND THE ISSUES
ALTHOUGH THERE DIFFICULT AND
WE'VE BEEN AT THEM FOR MANY
YEARS I THINK WE'RE SO CLOSE TO
MOVING FORWARD WITH SOMETHING
THAT'S GOOD FOR OUR TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS AS WELL AS
THE COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THAT DRIVE BENEFIT.
FROM THE ECONOMY'S RON ROOMS
AND HORSE RACING. THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FAIRS AND I
THINK TODAY. WITH THE
LEADERSHIP SHOWN BY CHAIRMAN
DODD THE SENATE THIS COMMITTEE
WE CAN RESET THOSE DISCUSSIONS
IN A WAY THAT MADE WITH THE
SPORT. AND I APPRECIATE THAT
LEADERSHIP I THINK BEFORE I
RESPECTFULLY DRIVE OUT. IF YOU
TAKE AN EDITOR CLOSER YOU GONNA
CLOSE THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL CITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR A- ALL
RIGHT THING THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
DIED AND TURNING GRAY AT THIS
POINT DO WE HAVE A MOTION IN
LIKE TWELVE TO MOVE THE CASE
ARCHULETA MOVEMENTS OF OCEAN IS
IT THE MEASURE BE ADOPTED. FOR
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JUST REMINDER TO WAIT
UNTIL YOUR MICROPHONE
MICROPHONE IS TURNED ON AND TO
SPEAK DIRECTLY INTO THE
MICROPHONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHT THREE EIGHT SIX THE
MOTION IS FOR THE MEASURE TO BE
ADOPTED EVERY FOR TO THE FROM.
DOT I. KNOW WELCOME NO ALLEN HI
OUR I HAVE TO HER ON UNTIL IT
ALL RIGHT WE'RE JUST NO BORDERS
NO BROWN HI BRADFORD ALL RIGHT.
GALGIANI HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HILL HI PHIL I WANT SOME.
NIELSEN NO NO FOR NOW
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
RUBIO. WIENER WIENER NINE THAT
HAS ABLE TO. WE CALL THE ROLL
AGAINST MISTER. THIS CALL THE
ROLL AGAIN. CHIANG GLAZER.
LATER ON MY WAY SO. RUBIO. THAT
HAS NINE THREE THE MEASURE OF
TIME. I'M SORRY I DID NOT HEAR
THAT BUT THAT'S NINETY THREE.
OKAY PAGE NINETY THREE SO
MEASURE IS OUT. NINE TO
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU
GRADUATION MISTER CHAIR. JUST
WHAT AM I THINKING ALL THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS.
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION. SO AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION IS ADJOURNED.